okay
the hour being 10 o'clock
we'll open up the public hearing on uh
senate bill 354 and hear from the prime
sponsor senator susie good morning
senator
for the record i'm donna soucy i
represent senate district 18 which is
comprised of the town of litchfield and
manchester's wards five through nine
and i'm here today to introduce senate
bill 354 which was a request of the
department of insurance to make changes
to their existing licensing statutes
these changes will do a few things
modify the adjuster's law to define good
cause for license
non-issuance
codify the practice that license renewal
fees are non-refundable
clarify that banks don't need a license
to sell credit life and accident
insurance
to resolve a conflict in existing
statutory law we want to be clear they
don't need to be licensed to sell
these products
and require the producer for a business
that sells insurance to actually hold a
license
for the lines that are being sold
during the senate hearings the insurance
industry
was in favor of these changes my
understanding is that josh hilliard is
here from the department to answer any
more technical questions that you have
but i would ask for your support of this
bill on behalf of the department i'd be
happy to answer any questions as i said
to the extent they're more technical in
nature you might get a more detailed
response from the department
thank you
great um i just realized my clerk just
walked in do you have written testimony
i do and i would be happy to share it
with you that would be perfect thank you
very much
okay see no questions from the committee
oh will you do it representative grayson
i just want to make sure that the and
the language thank you senator for for
coming uh
on line six of
uh of the text of the first page of the
text it says
uh
per violation or any combination or
actions should that be the combination
of actions or i'm not sure the sentence
reads maybe it's not enough caffeine or
too much caffeine or one or the other
it's not making sense to me in reading
that should it be of or i see what
you're saying um
why don't i have the department weigh in
because my understanding is a lot of
this language is consistent with other
parts of the statute i
believe
i believe it should be of but i'll have
them respond so we drink the same cup of
coffee good
thank you representative good catch
good great thank you
yes please so the insurance department i
are you oh i'm sorry that's okay
who's supposed to fill out the pink card
but okay you probably knew you're new to
this process here so that we in the
house different from the senate we
actually have these little cute pink
cards
i did fill one out but i attached it
over there
here it is it just suddenly appeared
it's a marble
okay josh go ahead great thank you mr
chairman members of the committee thank
you for your time this morning my name
is joshua hilliard i'm the compliance
and enforcement council at the new
hampshire insurance department and i'm
here to speak of course in favor of this
bill for the department today
so to to first address the question from
representative greeson uh i believe that
may um need to be in of as you identify
rather than an or in in that line
line six of that first page thank you
i'd like to speak briefly to each of
these changes but please you know
interrupt me at any point if you have
any questions about them
as identified by senator susie the first
change would modify
the licensure for
adjusters in terms of the penalties we
can bring and bring it in line with that
for insurance agents insurance producers
right now the statute only identifies
good cause as the reasons why the
department may bring an action against
an adjuster who has violated our laws
that's of course quite vague
this change would identify good cause to
include all of the reasons that are
enumerated under the statute to bring an
action against an insurance agent
the second change to 400 829
makes clear that not only are the
application fees non-refundable for
insurance you know producer or agent
license but the renewal fees as well
the third change would uh help eliminate
what is currently a conflict in our law
under 400
406 c
right now financial institutions both
banks and credit unions
are not required to obtain a license to
sell a limited line of credit insurance
unfortunately another part of our
statutes and that is 408 a9 indicates
that anyone selling credit insurance
must have a license there's a clear
conflict in the law the practice that
the department has meant to not require
of course under 406 c that a financial
institution have a license and this
change in the statute this third change
would eliminate that current conflict in
the law
the the fourth and final change
would make a change to the requirement
right now for designated responsible
licensed producers or persons drlps
and those are people that are identified
as the person responsible for an
entity's compliance with insurance law
so if an entity is producing selling
insurance they need to have a person who
is licensed who is responsible for that
entity's compliance with the law
currently under the law there's no
requirement that that individual who is
responsible for the entity's compliance
be licensed in the same lines that the
entity is which is an issue because you
could have a producer an insurance agent
who may be licensed to sell auto
insurance who could be named as a drlp
for an entity that's selling life
insurance and that person who is
licensed cell auto does not know life
and really how can they be responsible
for the compliance for that entity so
this change would just make it so that
the person or persons identified as the
drlp for that entity be licensed in the
lines that that entity is selling
i'm happy to answer any questions any me
we do have questions
representative van halen thank you good
morning and thank you for your testimony
i just have a
clarification for my own
sensibility i guess under the good cause
limitations or not limited to uh the
last one roman 12
doesn't directly deal with insurance as
do the others it deals with
um
court imposing child support obligation
and a violation thereof um that just
seems unusual all the others are related
to insurance i'm wondering why that
exists
that's a direct corollary representative
from the
producer law
where we have the same powers on the
producer law to bring action against an
entity who has failed to to a person
rather you know who has failed to pay a
child support order
the grounds for that
i'm really not best to speak to the
actual grounds for that i believe it's
probably because it comes from a model
okay
seeing none thank you very much thank
you for your time
i have no more cards on senate bill 3t4
anybody else like to testify speak now
forevermore hold your piece
uh the blue sheet uh we have ron mclean
uh
cooperative credit union support
uh john le course is nhid in support
heather
silverman
from the department also
and joan pagen uh representing new
hampshire association insurance agents
and support with that i will close the
oh
this is
yes and so and yes senator kevin
is also in support
okay
uh
oh
is
okay
oh
anyways
um
one
oh
okay
so we'll uh
call up trisha molino from the senator
cannon's office and since senator cannon
would not be able to make it she's here
to
give his written testimony right yes
it makes the clerk happy
thank you good morning mr chair and
committee members my name is trisha
molillo legislative aid for senator
introducing senate bill 204 and an
amendment to sb 204 at the request of
the insurance department to further
modify the definition of covered claim
in the new hampshire insurance guarantee
association act
the guaranty association was established
to protect property and casualty
policyholders from unfunded losses and
ensure that their claims are paid should
will be paid by the association and
policies originally issued by a
non-member will not be covered by the
association regardless of what company
has responsibility for the policy at the
time of the claim
the controlling issue is who issued the
original policy a member or non-member
the amendment to sb 204 helps further
clarify the issue the insurance industry
supports these changes
and heather silverstein
is here from the insurance department to
answer any questions you may have
thank you
great thank you very much
okay uh
heather
so
no doug
he was the good morning
he was originally supposed to be the
neic meeting so maybe he just thought
that
so this this change is uh and including
the amendment is just to further clarify
um this obligation you know what happens
if companies go into liquidation at some
point down the road and who has um
responsibility for the claims under
particular policy and we just wanted to
clarify in our law
that um
it's who
as long as there was a met it was a
member
um that issued the policy then that
policy would be covered regardless if
there was changes later um
with regard to the policy being owned or
you know uh under the control of a
different company later
and this came about because there has
been confusion in other states
and that have led to issues and we
didn't want that to happen in our state
okay any questions
yep representative abel
um are there any uh situations in which
a policyholder in new hampshire would
not have someone
making you know
uh
covering them
um
i mean uh
do we have to worry about anybody
uh any
individual policyholders who would not
be covered by this not for licensed
companies not for licensed vnc companies
it's more of like a if a non-licensed
company got the policy down the road and
then you know so the idea is these
license companies they pay into the
guaranty fund they support it and so
it's also consistency with that it's the
companies that are paying in those
policies should be covered later
most policies would be covered in new
hampshire because they'd be like delayed
the company would be licensed but if for
some reason it passed to a non-licensed
okay
thank you very much thank you and no
doug
okay
um
and this is your amendment that you guys
had drawn up
okay
and that was not the request of the
guarantee
all right uh
having
no more cards for does anybody want to
testify on senate bill 204
seeing none
close to public hearing
and
chris
kristen do you have a copy of this
okay so that we'll need that for
you
heather
yeah because
so it's just the one that has no name on
it
oh yeah 21 south fruit street is that
here yeah it's your address not your
name
[Laughter]
okay so for the record uh senate bill
204 both donna soucy senator susie and
senator reagan signed in
okay
hey
uh
okay why don't we open up the uh next
hearing senate bill 205 relative
insurance department administrative fund
and hear from trisha milio for senator
gannon good morning again
trisha malillo legislative aide for
senate bill 205 is introduced at the
request of the insurance department to
modify the way the department manages
their administration fund when there's
an overage at the beginning of the new
fiscal year
current language stipulates any overage
to be calculated as a pro rata offset a
portion to each individual insurer based
on their relative contribution to the
fund
the changes proposed by sb 205 will
allow for any overage to be generally
applied to reduce future assessments
across the board
mirroring the process spelled out in
statute for the department of labor and
their workers compensation
administration fund
the insurance industry is fine with this
change and michelle heaton is here from
the insurance department to answer any
questions you may have
great
all right so michelle heaton from the
thank you
good morning my name is michelle heaton
i'm the health law and policy legal
counsel at the insurance department and
i'm here to answer any questions you
guys may have about the bill
it's really um just a minor change and
it's going to help us make it much more
much easier for us to
calculate these assessments and send out
the notices
so you're i don't think i've we've met
before have we
have you i've been here before um i
usually testify on health bills but um i
was going to say you you don't look like
tyler to me but
yeah i work closely with tyler tyler
tyler's not here i'll be here in this
place i gotcha okay
all right we do have a question um
representative
thank you for for coming down i just
have a question
regarding the administration fund versus
the assessment fund are they one in the
same
okay
the question seen on thank you very much
uh
no more cards anybody want to testify on
this issue
that's
okay
uh
just
is the right bill
this is yeah
no this is this is 206 205.
okay 205 uh senator carson
and senator reagan in support and tony
piemont of
uh also
as a legislator is in support of the
bill
and the other blue sheet
we have joan pagen
of course heather is uh silver is also
in support from the insurance department
michelle heaton cited it again and then
tony
uh
piedmont is still in support of this
bill
okay
all right
with that i will close the public
hearing
just
oh
um
okay
is
oh
okay
um
is
oh i see it's dead clock see the clock
is different so i just looked up at that
one
open up the public hearing on senate
bill 205 and hear from the prime sponsor
senator french
good morning senator french what a
pleasure it is to have you oh mr care
you have no idea how excited i am to be
thank you mr chair for the record my
name is harold french i am senator from
district seven
and um
i'm here to present senate bill 206
which is a really great and important
bill
this bill
is a request of the insurance department
to remove prepaid legal contracts from
regulation by the insurance department
it makes certain clarifications
regarding consumer guarantee contracts
also known as service contracts
this bill is a little complicated as you
might well guess
and the department is here to speak to
it in great depth and detail
thank you mr chair
well
thank you mr chairman
any questions for the chair of the
senate commerce committee saying never
ask the chairman embarrassing questions
just remember that representative
representative johnson
how did this come out of committee in
5-0
consent
i would say you could look to stock it
you're just
checking his memory
and by the way representative that's one
strike
weren't you in his district
right but he's done now you heard it
right
okay uh
so the next oh call up uh james fox from
i i i didn't fill out the card
yeah my name is james fox i'm the
property director and i'm also up here
with heather silva's team who's the
general counsel at the department um
this uh bill senate bill 206 actually
has uh two pieces one piece is the
consumer guarantee a little closer to
the money i'm sorry
one piece is the consumer guarantee
contract piece um that senator french
mentioned and then there's also an
amendment to add a piece about the
department's uh investigation uh statute
400 a16 and that's what um general
counsel silverstein will discuss so i'm
only here for the consumer guarantee
contract piece
as uh senator french
noted uh the consumer guarantee contract
uh law
is was designed for him and handles
service contracts and also some people
call them um extended warranties that's
the thing when you buy an item at a
store they say would you like an
extended warranty or if you buy a car
they say would you like an extended
warranty um that is how what the law in
my opinion was designed for and it works
very well for that and we regulate that
and we
help consumers understand their rights
under those contracts um but uh in
addition to that also what was added to
that law was a prepaid legal contracts
and those are contracts where
you um you may have seen them on on
television you like legal zoom you you
enter into a contract and then if you
have some legal questions uh you can uh
call and they'll provide you with a
lawyer to answer some simple legal
questions now in that area
i've been with the department 10 years
we've never had one complaint that we've
handled as to those issues
and also are really our only role in
that at this point is we occasionally
have a company ask us if their
particular contract falls within our law
or doesn't fall within our law
which sometimes is a little bit
difficult to answer because the current
statute is very subjective like
if they can answer simple questions then
there's always a question what's a
simple question so um
you know and so basically after
consideration by the department it felt
like our our resources were better spent
on the more emerging actual insurance
products that are coming out uh because
they're actually getting much more uh
high tech let's call it so their reviews
getting more extensive and to to remove
this particular uh product from uh the
consumer guarantee uh statute because
it's it's it's in the department's uh
opinion not something that we need to
regulate
um to protect consumers
obviously at some point in time if there
was if there were a problem in the
future we would reconsider that position
but at this point after over a decade we
don't feel it's necessary now the other
piece of the consumer guarantee contract
part of the bill that we are asking to
have included
is
something called pro rata return so if
you have say you have an automobile
policy um and you you pay um
geico for six months uh then you decide
to cancel it halfway through you get
half your money back that's a pro rata
return um that is how it operates in
pers almost all personal lines except if
you have like a short term policy uh
then like you're you're
getting insurance for an uh like an
event or or a
trip then it's a little different
because the risk is not spread out over
that full period of time so those we
don't require to be pro rata um we
didn't have that in the consumer
guarantee contract um and we thought we
and we had some um insurance companies
that were not insurance companies some
consumer guarantee company contract
companies who were
balking at the parata idea but most of
them do it so the thought was to just
put it in the law that
you have to do it pro rata if
it's
a contract that's a year
uh or more and then what they're a lot
what we allow them to do because they
said well there is a cost to our you
know processing these things is that
they can have
10 of the contract price but with a cap
of 75
for two in essence to to minister the
the cancellation and then the rest goes
back to the consumer and that is um
generally how it works uh in
um
regular insurance we allow fees as long
as they're reasonable we felt this was a
reasonable fee so we thought this would
um end the issue of what the return
should be and we wouldn't have
complaints about like i got an extended
warranty
for my car and i you know i sold my car
fairly shortly thereafter so i don't
need it and i'm having trouble getting
my money back
um so now we can point to a law and say
you have to do it and ends the
discussion
so those are the two consumer guarantee
contract issues and i'll let heather
good morning again
so the amendment that we would like
for our statute 400 a16 which is
pertaining to investigations that the
department does
currently the statute
requires it states that the commissioner
shall adopt rules pursuant to 541a
to identify documents obtained during a
consumer
investigation of the department
that potentially could be disclosed to a
consumer
that is really a
difficult
language for us it's requiring us to
adopt those rules where we the amendment
we would like was to be as may be
necessary so if those rules are needed
then we could adopt those rules and we
have that in other statutes
at the current time there's not a
need to adopt those rules so we don't
want to be required to go through the
administrative process to drop rules
where it's not necessary
so
okay any questions from
committee members
yeah representative abel
yes uh thank you for your testimony um
if uh the um
if the prepaid legal contract
is no longer uh
um
part of you're not overseeing those
where would a consumer go to uh
to contact someone in the state about a
problem
that's an excellent question and i
actually was supposed to say that but i
forgot to
so there's i wrote there's really three
options one we're talking about
attorneys so you go to the bar
association if you have a complaint
about an attorney and that scares any
attorney more than anything else in the
world uh way more than insurance
department would uh other one the next
one is you could have you bring a
contract claim against the company and
then the last one is it would then in
the department's opinion fall back to
the consumer protection act so that
remember there was some time when they
went back and forth did what's the
latest with the the bar association
being under the consumer protection act
because i know at one point in time they
were in and lawyers were out learners
are in i don't know what what is the
current status of that yeah you know i'm
not sure about the current status but if
you actually if you if you look at so
you would get a lawyer but
these are really companies that are
providing you with lawyers so you could
even if the lawyers write i think you go
after the company itself like that they
didn't provide you the look so they're
basically saying they're going to
provide you a lawyer
or they're gonna or they're gonna they
have a lawyer they're gonna pay you
money to get a lawyer so um
if you wanna go after the lawyer you
definitely go to the bar association and
if you wanna go after the company i
think you go after the consumer
protection act and maybe with the lawyer
you go after both i'm not sure
but there is a an exemption on the
consumer protection act for insurance so
this is sort of like right so that that
gap just to make sure that if there was
some laps somewhere there you would end
the day you would be on the insurance
departments right that's always in and
you know that's always how how we we
look at things is okay when we regulate
it
there's a lot of exemptions then that's
what we do and then if we don't well
where does it fall so that's always was
part of the process of making sure that
consumers to the extent there were
problems would be protected
perfect
yes represent van halen thank you and
thank you for coming before us this
morning i have a question about the
amendment if i may please
um the quest the question relates to
language and i understand that this new
language
and the third they're not numbered but
the third line down the sentence begins
the commissioner shall adopt rules
pursuant
and then it says as may be necessary is
there a conflict between the word shall
and the words as may be necessary they
seem to be shell is like must and as may
be necessary as yeah maybe
no so we have this in other statutes as
well as to our rulemaking authority so
we shall adopt them as made me necessary
so it's if there's a need for the rules
then we would adopt and so that gives us
the flexibility rather than we have to
adopt rules when there's no need to
adopt rules and nobody wants us to adopt
rules
sort of sounds like a chicken in the
yang
you want to have the child to tell you
you have to do something
and then you have the may says oh well
nobody really feels a need for it so we
don't have to do it versus is just
taking the shower and say may up front
is someone might say is
the department wants to make the rules
and say well you don't have to and then
they get bogged down and arguing about
why they don't have to where in this
case you're saying the the
represent van gaal thank you just a
quick follow-up
um is there a definition for necessary
in this context i understand the word
necessary but in this context is there a
definition
and i don't mean to put you on the spot
at all i'm just trying to understand
this no but typically i mean i look at
it practically you know is there some
reason um like for a consumer protection
related reason or the licensee also for
our licensees is there some reason that
further regulate
these these investigations are these are
our insurance products and so that i use
i view it and i think most of us at the
department would view it that way too
okay
any other questions
see none thank you very much for your
testimony thank you
all right
representing the service council
industry
council
council council
services
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee my name is jim hadem uh i'm
here uh on behalf of the
service
contract industry council which is the
trade association for the companies that
write
extended warranties and service
contracts
and
we are here in to speak in
support of this bill and particularly
section two which relates to the refunds
that
james had mentioned earlier and
part of the discussion about this
amendment was uh when its first
iteration it was just strictly everyone
had to issue refunds
and um we
mentioned
to the department that you know these
contracts aren't all uniform they have
different durations and as james
explained you know there's a lot of them
that are written month to month and are
kind of low dollar amounts so
you know this is actually the biggest
industry here is
service line contracts utility line
contracts
to you know between that serve take care
of the
service lines between the water and
sewer lines between someone's house and
the and that's you
municipality service line and those are
typically a few dollars a month
um and then you have
service contracts that are longer
duration that's typically auto service
contracts and you know equipment service
contracts and as james said those are
higher dollar amounts so in the context
of this discussion we we discussed the
uh
the way of addressing the distinction
through this
through uh requiring the refund only for
12-month contracts and allowing for
administrative charge and
this
bill currently balances those interests
quite well and we support this bill as
and
what james had mentioned earlier
or on the way over is i think there
no i'm sorry
yeah in line 22
or 24 i didn't have it in front of me
because there's a misreference in one or
two so
i think there's a subcommittee tomorrow
i think the department will be able to
point which one i got which one it is by
tomorrow
so
that's it's just there's
i think the roman numeral two
in roman numeral one on line 22 the
so anyway we'll we'll have that nailed
well it'd be nice if we can get it
solved today so that we'll know when we
take up the amen when we take up this
amendment
we'll solve it today
okay so and kristen behind you is who
okay
you gotta jump all right
okay otherwise otherwise we would have
to have another subcommittee so it would
be nice to have the amendment correct
otherwise for tomorrow we can figure
that right now soon okay great
so make sure i understand this when
you're talking about
i have
uh um
when we get our new cell phones
and we get this i know that this
legislation was related to this way back
when at some point in time i think like
i was the sponsor of it
and uh so the
changing to 12 months so when i
sign up when i get my new phone and i
sign up for the service contract it it
they bill me
monthly
but have i really signed up for a
contract that's more than two years
or more than a year or they might you
know what whatever the length of the
purchase
so you'd have to you know you have to
know exactly when you signed
up but certainly you know there are
there are certainly um service contracts
that are uh
a year or more of duration that are
billed monthly i don't think that
yeah
so this since this would focus is on the
duration of the contract
okay so i just need to make sure it
it it really is a long is it for the
life of it right until uh
i paid off the phone right which is the
way it's sort of sold as but i never
it is true i've never read the fine
print there's a big booklet that comes
with that
okay
any other questions from the community
remember seeing them thank you very much
thank you
uh i have no more cards
and
the blue sheets
i got uh joan
vaginal is still here new hampshire
insurance agent still in support
and
senator kavanaugh and senator susie
senator carson and senator reagan are
all in support
evidently the senators are taking
advantage of our online
system
more than we'd probably take advantage
of theirs well that's right they don't
okay seeing a number of cards and we'll
close the public hearing
yeah
you
okay we'll open up the public hearing on
senate bill 207 and hear from the prime
sponsor senator french
good morning again senator french
once again good morning to the committee
for the record i still am
senator harold french senator for
district 7.
i'm here to introduce to you today
senate bill 207 at the request of the
insurance department to clarify that a
company's cost of retaining an outside
expert for review
of their annual statements will be
credited towards their assessed
administrative fees for the subsequent
year only
the current language suggests such
credit may be carried over into future
fiscal years but since this credit
pertains to an annual review cost the
practice is to apply only to the
subsequent year
any future credit earned for costs
associated with future annual reviews
will likewise be applied only to the
year subsequent to the year such credit
is earned
the industry the insurance industry is
fine with this clarifying change and
michelle heaton is here from the
insurance department to answer any
questions you may have and as a side
note
it came out of committee 5-0
was put on consent and passed on a voice
vote
thank you mr chair for doing your
homework
for my committee members
so it could have been that the old days
the fees
were such that that there was really a
carryover to multiple years and now the
fees are such that there isn't it could
be i mean
all right okay thank you very much thank
you have a great day you too
okay so
doug bartlett from the new hampshire
i'm the health law and policy legal
counsel and i have doug bartlett here as
well and he should be able to answer
your questions probably a little bit
better than i could
well
this section of the law was enacted to
be able to contract for analysis
assistance if it was needed
the consultants would be paid for by the
insurance companies that they assisted
with the department's analysis
and those insurance companies would be
able to offset payments to these
consultants with a credit to the
administrative assessment
this assessment is an assessment to pay
for the cost of the insurance department
based on the amount of premiums an
insurance company wrote in new hampshire
and the total amount of the assessment
is not lowered by this this is added to
the assessment and then taken back in so
we're not getting less money because we
in the first year we did 47 had 47
companies and that's the little misnomer
that liberty mutual had 19 the hanover
had seven
uh and this year uh
we only used 14 companies well for last
year this year we are not using
consultants we've been able to hire
three people
since two years ago and so we're all uh
doing that all ourselves now
so if in i i guess i just answer
questions that anybody has any questions
relating to how it works
um let me just add one thing that a lot
of these companies don't write much here
in new hampshire and so if it costs like
maybe four thousand dollars to do their
analysis
and and they write very little here it
could take like 30 years
to actually collect that
uh so
that's that's why we just said you know
this is we're doing it for this year
this is the year that you can take the
credit
okay
any other
i mean i guess
hiring of consultants because you're
assuming that you don't
have the expertise in-house for this
okay this is an analysis we analyze all
of our domestic companies every year
and you build them ahead of time right
you bill them for this analysis work no
no this is part of their
when they make their contribution
assessment
if we don't hire consultants no we don't
build them that's part of the built-in
assessment
right okay okay but if we if we need to
hire experts and that it was brought on
with basically you know we had a
ameri retired and we had two two right
analysts die i mean
we just
we just weren't ready and you know it
was a one of these things when we just
had to do something because you know we
we have to
fit the schedule of the neic and all
states all 50 states have to do that and
there are certain time limits
especially for your annual analysis and
you know we didn't hire them to do the
analysis we hired them as the first
review uh
i mean it just it was impossible
really
we we couldn't have done it all
by june 1st
all right
are we all set
okay have no cards nobody else wants to
weigh in uh
and
the blue sheet is two insurance
department members and
is senators
senator carson uh senator reagan and
senator hennessey are all in support of
the bill
and say none we will close the public
hearing
and the committee is in recess until one
o'clock
yes
okay
we'll open up the public hearing on
senate bill 208 relative to life
insurance
and
are you the defining sponsor center
canada
uh okay here's a card okay good and i
know you didn't do this card because
this is this is very nice handwriting
nick and nice handwriting as
someone someone who went to parochial
school i can tell i know i know that
handwriting
okay
he keeps me on time and uh
i don't want to say looking good but
that's it on time
okay just make sure the mic is close to
you because
now i'm standing that it's being
recorded on youtube but we actually have
marvels of technology here where our
clerk is actually going to take your
words and
well thank you mr chairman and thank you
committee members it's a pleasure to be
here my name is kevin kavanagh i'm the
senator from district 16 representing
the towns of beau candia dunbarton
hooksett and manchester awards one two
and 12.
um i'm introducing senate bill 208 at
the request of the insurance department
to update and modernize rsa 408 which
regulates life insurance
this rewrite project has been ongoing
for a couple years
in 2020 the department requested senate
bill 664 that was stripped out and
out the outdated and obsolete provisions
of rsa 408
that bill passed the senate on a voice
boat but then was tabled in the house
because of the when the pandemic hit
the language proposed in senate bill 208
not only strips out the old provisions
but also revises the remaining
provisions to bring them up to date
resulting in a proposal to repeal and re
reenact rsa 408
the department provided a legend to
committee members that references the
proposed changes section by section
michelle heaton is here from the
insurance department to what all right
thank you
see no questions you're all set all
right thank you
all right uh michelle
eaton
there she is
hello and before i get going did you
guys get a copy of the legend table i
have it here so i can pass it around to
everyone
so this is an index to
figuring out what's all in here
yes that's correct so for the record my
name is michelle heaton i'm the health
law and policy legal counsel
at the insurance department
so the insurance department has been
working for several years to update new
hampshire's life insurance statute and
to bring it into modern times the
current 408 or rsa 408 contains several
outdated provisions which were first
enacted
as far back as 1850.
the department originally sought to
update
for rsa40i into two phases first by
removing all the outdated and
duplicative provisions
and then the second phase would be to
update and expand the remaining
provisions as necessary
as senator cavanaugh already let you
know that
first phase started going and then the
pandemic kit so it got tabled and then
we decided we're just going to do it all
as one
one
so since
2020 we have now completed a proposal
for updating and monitorizing the life
so this legend here that's being passed
around because it's a complete repeal
and re-enactment helps guide people the
left-hand side is what the current 408
is and then there's the re the reasons
why it's either repealed or where it got
or how it's been amended as well
so as you'll see a lot of the provisions
have been repealed as they're either no
longer necessary or they're covered by
other statutes for example um
there are the old 408.5 or the current
408.5 relating to agents
is we don't need that in 408 because
it's already covered by
rsa402j which is specific to insurance
producers so there's a lot of
duplicative provisions in the current
408 right now so we want to move those
out to make
it easier for people to find because if
you're looking at
statutes relating to insurance producers
you would not think to look in the
insurance of the life insurance statute
so there's a lot of things that have
been repealed because they're in they're
covered in other sections of the
title 37 relating to insurance
we've also for the stuff that's
remaining we've also updated the
language to bring it into modern times
and some of the provisions that are
based off of naic models we have also
updated that language because the model
may have been
adopted you know 20 30 years ago and the
model has since been amended we're just
adding in that new language too so it
better aligns with the current versions
so rather than walking through every
single change that we've made because
it's quite extensive i'd be happy to
answer any questions
okay yep representative paul
no he's not here
[Laughter]
depalma's not here
since you are utilizing this is a
complete rewrite it sounds like from uh
existing uh laws going back as far as
1850 all right yes uh is is this
primarily the nic model
that you're using and i guess what i'm
asking is would you would you be able to
highlight any particular sections
[Music]
of
this
of this bill that are new hampshire
specific
peculiar to new hampshire
so there isn't an naic model that's just
for life insurance okay and that would
be
that would incorporate everything that's
in 408 there are multiple models that
have been incorporated into different
sections of 408 so for example there's a
model about group life insurance so
those provisions are included in our
rewrite but that would only be one naic
model so there are certain things um
i'm trying to think like our form our
form filings and review
that's basically how most states operate
i'm not sure that there's necessarily an
naic model on it so that might be a
little bit specific some of those time
periods could be specific to new
hampshire um
trying to think of something else
there's various aspects of different
models that get incorporated in here so
i'm not sure which one quick follow for
the question
so there there's there's nothing here
with reference to the reference
materials that you
utilized and
incorporated into this rewrite
that were either
changed because
uh
of new hampshire specific concerns
yes sir am i are you getting me
kind of yeah
here's another way putting this could
could could this bill
if if uh if if pennsylvania
uh we're in the same position as new
hampshire with respect to the need to do
a rewrite which you acknowledge
uh
are there any substantial sections of
not knowing pennsylvania i would say no
in that
every every state their laws are
slightly different
we didn't change anything that was in
408 to make it more new hampshire
specific there could have been things
that were already in 408 that we
didn't take out
but we may have tweaked it to better
align with the national standard or with
the naic guidelines
okay there's nothing peculiar to new
hampshire
no thank you
and i would venture to say that you um
because given that how much case law
might be
driven by the statute you really don't
want to change
anything in terms of actual legal
process because you you don't want to
upset the cart when it comes to the
courts having to say we have to change
it because it was changed by the statute
no as we were going through the rewrite
if there was something if there was some
kind of case law and i'm not thinking of
anything specific to 408 but had there
been some kind of case law that um
interpreted 408 in a particular way we
may have clarified the language in 408
to be consistent with what that
legal precedent was right and i and i do
do see the the section with nic model
was used
so
okay
any other questions from the community
members seeing them thank you very much
does anybody else would like to testify
on senate bill 208
see none
close the hearing and uh well i guess
before i hit the gavel right um nobody
signed in the blue sheet
online
fellow senators were all done and then
uh but we do have
um joan
pagino is still here new hampshire show
station of independent agents still earn
support
and the department people and then of
course the senator
signed in again
so
with that
no
yesterday the first one
are you going to interview yeah
um
uh
yes
open up the public hearing on senate
bill 285 relative to discount medical
plan organizations
and hear from the prime sponsor senator
cavanaugh good
afternoon again senator cavanaugh good
afternoon again thank you again mr
chairman
um and committee members again my name
is kevin cavanaugh representing senate
district 16 the towns of beau candia
dunbarton hooksett and manchester wards
1 2 and 12.
i'm introducing senate bill 285 at the
request of the insurance department to
incorporate additional provisions of the
national association of insurance
commissioners model law number 98 on
discount medical plan organizations
these updates add additional requested
information on the registration
application
minimum capital requirements
registration renewal procedures
conditions for suspension revocation of
registration
michelle heaton is here from the
insurance department to go into more
detail on this and answer any questions
of the committee and thank you very much
for your consideration and i hope you
have a
quick afternoon
any questions from the committee
no
okay
okay thank you thank you all right
michelle
eaton from the insurance department who
hi again michelle heaton from the new
hampshire insurance department i'm the
health law and policy legal counsel
and to answer your question this bill is
amending the registration requirements
for um discount medical plans can you
explain what that is a discount medical
plan yeah so these are not insurance
these are um discount plans where a
person could either
subscribe pay a monthly fee join some
app something like that and in doing so
they would have access to
potential discounts on health services
so for example common one would be a
drug discount plan and you've probably
seen commercials for these on tv where
you know you have this app or you pay
this
fee of five dollars a month and when you
go to the pharmacy you can show them
this card and you may get a better
discount than what you would get with
your insurance so my
my
my farm is just reached over the counter
and just grabs his card and hands it to
me yeah submerged to
that okay so that's what we're talking
about these those people
yes okay yes
so and they're not insurance because
there is no risk you're not guaranteed
any discount and some of these services
are available
without ever actually collecting any
money from patients or clients or
consumers
they're available to anyone
so what we're trying to do with this
bill is just make sure that these
organizations have minimal minimum
and that if they
are no longer solvent we have the
ability to revoke their registration to
okay
representative terry thank you mr
chairman
uh so do i understand that now to get
very specific here with an example
um i have a good rx a discount card for
pharmacy there currently there's no
regulation
of good rx but under this statute there
would now be regulation of good rx and
similar entities
so we do already regulate discount
medical plans we have
we adopted the model the naic model
number 98
relating to discount medical plans and
the chapter
rsa415i is specific to discount medical
plans what we're doing here is we're
only changing the registration
requirements to put in some minimum
standards
so in order now if this were to pass in
order to get this registration you would
as part of the registration process we
would be asking whether your
registration had been suspended denied
revoked in any other jurisdiction if
you're under investigation in any other
jurisdiction
um and then we'd also ask them to
present evidence showing a network
net worth of at least 150 000
so we're just putting in these
additional requirements to make sure
that these types of plans
are solvent and are not operating in a
representative mack later
thank you very much
a question a couple of questions if you
don't mind how many of these
organizations do we have in new
hampshire right now do you know
i do not know but i can get back to you
on that
and second question so this really has
nothing to do with the
with what they offer it really has to do
with the organization itself is that
correct
how they're structured and and the fact
that they're financially
sound as opposed to
you you have to if you're going to offer
this you got to be it's going to look
like that or there's nothing to do with
that as i understand it
this amendment is only talking about the
financial regulations but overall the
chapter there are regulations okay about
how you advertise and there has to be
disclaimers the the concern that comes
about with these is we don't want these
types of plans being marketed as being
health insurance
or having similar benefits to health
insurance and sometimes they can be
marketed in a way that would confuse
consumers so the reason we have this
statute is to make sure that to the
extent these entities are operating in
new hampshire they're meeting those
requirements that there's proper
disclosures so that there is no
confusion with whether this is medical
insurance and what it's going to cover
and that there is no guarantee this is
yes
thank you for your testimony and my
question um and and see the commissioner
um
can get information um that would help
him make his decision but
number three
he's judging whether someone is of good
character and i question what does that
mean and how would that determination be
made
so the good character is um the type of
provision we do have in some of our
other registration licensing
requirements
what that generally includes is that
there would be background checks for the
um
the board of directors or whoever is
running running this entity and that the
reason we have those in place is because
people who have
engaged in fraudulent activities in
other states with other entities we
don't want them just establishing this
new entity and coming into our state and
potentially doing something like that so
it's usually one of the requirements we
have
just to make sure that those bad actors
are not allowed to do that in new
hampshire follow-up
for the question may inquire
um
shouldn't we spell that out because
i totally understand what you're saying
and i think it's good um but we don't
say that it has to be a background check
or anything like that i just
i'm wondering if we should be more
specific about
that particular thing so that it's not
arbitrary or capricious in any way
we could this is the language used in
the model
and one of the drawbacks to putting in
too much limiting language there is that
if we were to put in something like you
had to have been convicted of fraud well
this person could be under investigation
in many states a lot of people are
looking at them maybe they had
settlement agreements but there was no
actual conviction of fraud so would that
qualify under here
you know that's the type of thing that
good character encompasses all of those
types of situations and that is what is
in the naic model but if the committee
feels that needs to be amended we'd be
happy to work with you on better
language
um for the question yeah
i think the background check minimally
might be something that we
would want to put in as a requirement
but again i
do you always do a background check
is that part of the process
currently for these no because there is
no requirement for that it depends on
the type of entity so for example
uh tpa's third party administrators in
their um application that is part of one
of the requirements to become an
insurance company if you're filing an
application for that you definitely need
to have background checks for everyone
that's going to be involved in the
management so it is something that's
typically done for a lot of our licensed
and regulated entities but
currently for the discount medical plans
there's
minimal very very minimal provisions of
who can apply for these and there's
not much done to oversee
who's getting these registrations or not
and that's why we're trying to get this
language
adopted so that we can do a better job
of regulating who is allowed to operate
as a discount medical plan
thank you very much
okay representative johnson
thank you for taking my question
um kind of piggybacking on what uh
representative fargo said
so there
any nowhere else in the statue it
doesn't define because that was my
question
it doesn't define what a good character
is anywhere else in the statue no
okay
representative
following on
the
um
troublingly vague
description good character
do you have you don't have in law do you
have an administrative
procedures or manuals
a
a definition of good character is it
described elsewhere i thought i heard
you made reference to
something or somewhere else
no this the standard of good care are of
good character appears in various
statutes but i don't believe we have any
administrative rules that further define
what good character is usually it's in
the
um
at the discretion of the commissioner so
if the commissioner finds you're not of
good character that would be a basis for
denying an application
follow the question it seems to me that
um
that an improvement could be made here
by providing some specific some
measurements
some specificity
uh this is troublingly vague
and
it seems to me it would be
for the applicant as well as for the
the party who's going to be making the
determination if i was in a position of
having to determine good character that
was not defined in any way
i would be i'd be uncomfortable with
that so i i think some thought should be
representative
thank you mr chair
um thank you for taking my question
actually it's not a question it's just
uh follow-up
there is a definition of good character
good character have traits like
integrity honesty courage loyalty
fortitude and other important virtues
that promote good behavior
so there is a definition
yeah that's a webster's dictionary
it is
[Music]
yes yes
webster's
um i asked about it being in statue
so okay we'll take this up
subcommittee
okay any other questions from the
committee members
see none thank you very much for your
testimony
um
i guess the joan
pagino uh is still here and
and michael eden and uh obviously
michelle is in support and kevin support
so nothing's changed oh we do have
somebody
is this the right bill
ellen aaron bond
from los angeles california
representing the consumer health
alliance
no i'm sure i'm sure they represent
these like type entities i just love to
know how this business model works
i mean how do they
how do they they give you a discount but
you know
why do why do pharmacies or why did
anybody do the discount where house i
just don't i've always been marveled by
the the
good good rx
it's good rx is it
it's just selling the data
that must be what it is yeah
okay
you ready uh i need a minute i'm just
you
good afternoon senator good afternoon
welcome to the house commerce committee
thank you
tell us what you have here great i'm
happy to and thank you mr chairman good
afternoon
for the record i'm cindy rosenwald
and i represent senate district 13 which
is most of nashua
and today i have for you
senate bill 121
this is enabling legislation which will
allow
new hampshire to exercise more local
control
and potentially save individuals
significant money on premiums that they
might purchase in the individual market
for health insurance
following the passage of the affordable
care act in 2010
we enacted
a law to prohibit the state from using a
state-based health benefit exchange
mandating instead that we use the
federal marketplace
and that's worked out okay
but we do have to pay
a three percent assessment
per enrollee for being
involved with healthcare.gov
um and that adds up to nearly eight
but in the 12
years since the law was passed
and enacted private businesses have
developed market-based solutions for
state health benefit exchanges
and this could be an option for new
hampshire that would give us more data
better data on who is signing up for
what and give us more control so brokers
and carriers could better serve the
unique needs of granite staters
it could also save up to four million
dollars a year
versus paying that three percent
assessment
fee
and this could accrue to
reduce
those health insurance premiums
and in addition the federal government
could layer more money on top of that
making the potential savings even
greater so let me just say again
this is enabling legislation
the insurance department would not be
able to
decide on their own to do this they
would still have to get
approval
from
the oversight committee on
health care reform plus the joint fiscal
committee so they would have to get
approval from
two different committees
it really removes the prohibition on
having a state-based exchange giving us
options for
a better product at a at a lower cost
through commercial enterprises and i
think i'll stop there i'm happy to take
questions but there are
other people here
really more well versed in this subject
matter
thank you mr chairman
thank you
representative burroughs
thank you for taking my question senator
um would this
eliminate the federal exchange in new
hampshire and my second part is are
there any benefits to being part of the
federal
exchange
it wouldn't
eliminate it it would give the insurance
department the ability to examine
not using it
i
can't imagine we would ever use two
different exchanges
but
if we found out we'd have better
control better data at lower cost it
would give us the option
to use
a non-federal
health benefit exchange i mean i think
the benefit at the time we did it was
that
it was less expensive
than trying to build our own state
exchange as some
states did but a lot of states
used the federal health benefit exchange
and as you probably remember it
got a rocky start
but um the
kicks got worked out of it and and
really was
fine
my daughter uses it
to purchase health insurance and
she doesn't have any trouble but i think
people would be happier
if
their health insurance premiums were
lower because we were able to find a
model that cost less
thank you very much
uh thank you very much uh just a
question would would the state be able
to
to basically take the federal
medical bill and trim it down
in other words make it uh
maybe less expensive by trimming
benefits
i don't believe so but if i'm wrong i'm
sure i'll be corrected
representative fargo
um yes i i have two questions
um
as far as the
federal regulations i believe
um
i i can't remember but i think we passed
a bill here in new hampshire that says
that new hampshire has to provide
the same benefits that are afforded
under the
aca
if i'm not mistaken i believe that is in
statute already tyler's yeah thank you
i'm not so sure would that hold true for
this this would not change the benefits
this would just change the process
of how you
enrolled
in a in a plan thank you my second
question
is there a reason i mean usually when we
see something like this there's a study
done and it comes
the results of this study come back to
us as another bill and the house and
senate then have the opportunity to vote
on that and my cons i guess my concern
or my question is is
why why would you do this study and then
implement it without bringing it back to
well
so
there's not a study committee here it
has the insurance department to evaluate
the options but then it's come back to
two legislatively established committees
one being the joint committee on health
care reform
which
i've been on and i think i might be on
again
is that the one we're on together
is that the oversight yes the joint
healthcare oversight reform committee
that
is charged
with um making decisions policy
decisions to the extent that the state
can
on
health care reform and the other one is
the joint fiscal committee
which looks at
changes to
state and federal spending in new
hampshire
throughout
the session even when
we're not all in session so i think
there is still
good control both on the policy and the
money from both the house and the senate
but it enables a little bit of
nimbleness
thank you
yes thank you there here i am there you
are
hi you're hiding um
i think you referenced i believe you
referenced that there are states that um
adopted and implemented their own models
yes
which states adopted models which have
worked out well
to the effect that i believe you
identified
they were able to provide
the same services at lower costs to
their state's residents
so thank you for that question um
i think what i was referencing was that
in after 2010
i'm gonna try and move this so i can
look at you when i talk
um some states and i know for example
new york state and massachusetts the big
states built their own state exchanges
but there are states also that have
adopted these commercial products and
there is a gentleman here from one of
those companies
to speak and he'd be able better to tell
you what states
so the question man so without without
identifying specific states which i
don't believe you're able to do at this
point that's okay
um
you're quite confident that there are
states that have adopted models
that have
produced benefits
that are favorable to to consumers
yes from a financial standpoint because
we've already heard that that the
product has to be the same
it's just the process is different such
that
there's a savings
provided by a state
mechanism rather than the federal
mechanism yes what i'm not sure is
whether all those states have elected to
pass the savings on
to consumers in the form of lower
premiums but
i certainly would
hope and expect that that's what new
hampshire would do
representative johnson
thank you for taking my question
um
with the if this bill were to pass does
that mean we would not be sending
any of our uh
residents to the federal we would just
let them pick from the state and that
that's where the savings would come in
or would we still have to offer both
so we'd still end up paying the federal
fees thank you for the question no we
wouldn't do both this bill would just
authorize the insurance department to
take a look at
whether
there's a better less expensive option
they're not allowed to even consider
one of these commercial products right
now under state law so this is just
enabling legislation to
allow the insurance department to
evaluate whether we could be
getting a better deal for new hampshire
consumers
we would not
but as i i read the last sentence here
the department would then
uh go out to bid
and get a proposal
and make a recommendation to the
governor and council for a vote
right but it was would already have gone
through
joint health care review reform
oversight and fiscal
in addition to a contract having to be
approved by the executive council so
there there's really a lot of
representative johnson
so
with that being said wouldn't this make
more sense for a study committee
so that we could
better see if that's something that was
actually needed or wanted
before we
go through all of this
well this i mean the
house will do
what the house
wants to do but
um i and the other sponsors thought we
should have the insurance department do
that study
because
they could
do it
okay no more questions thank you very
much thank you
okay chair we'll call on peter bragnan
representing pretty strategies oh
petty that's right
um
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee for the record peter bragdon
senior policy advisor with pretty
strategies
here representing getting short
with jason sparks
current new hampshire law rsa 420 n7
prohibits any state agency from even
planning to implement a state exchange
let alone implementing one
there are many benefits however to a
state exchange and jason can talk about
that
this bill simply authorizes the
department insurance to look into it and
if they feel it's warranted based on the
criteria you see in the bill also
authorize the implementation but only
upon approval of the legislative fiscal
committee and the hhs oversight
committee that's one thing by the way
i'll point out senator rosenwald spoke
of the the joint health care reform
oversight committee the original version
of the bill had that in there which was
a committee formed when we when the aca
was implemented
to specifically deal with issues related
to the affordable care act the senate
changed that to be the health and human
services oversight committee uh
obviously the house committee can
do what uh what they see fit he took
took heard me out of it
well
we would all prefer uh representative
hunt that you be a part of this so uh
we would be open to a change of any sort
that
allows that
uh let's see a little bit of history so
back in 2011 2012 i was in the senate at
the time
the legislature grappled with how to
implement the new affordable care act
that had been passed down in washington
uh also known as the aca
a key question of the aca is what to do
for an exchange uh under the aca every
state needed to provide a an exchange a
a portal a marketplace a place where
individuals can go
compare insurance plans and select which
ones they want to do
states could create their own exchange
or they could use the federal exchange
which is now known as healthcare.gov
they could not do both they had to do
one or the other
at the time we in the legislature were
very concerned that the state had
neither the resources nor the expertise
to create our own custom exchange from
scratch
plus at the time healthcare.gov was free
so we selected the federal exchange and
put into statute that agencies cannot
work to implement
a state exchange
here we are now 10 years later however
and there's a market that's grown for
companies to provide off-the-shelf
software as a solution for states not
some custom-built thing from scratch but
an off-the-shelf program that can be
tailored get insured as one of those
companies there are several others they
provide exchange for
let's see 17 states
right now have state exchanges
getting short i believe provides the
services for seven of them i believe
there's three more that are currently
in the process procurement process for
uh switching to a state exchange so soon
there'll be 20 of the 50 states that use
a state-based exchange with many of them
having switched from the federal
exchange for various reasons some of
which we'll say here
in addition to that what was once free
healthcare.gov now has a significant
cost the federal exchange healthcare.gov
is funded by a 2.75
tax on individual health insurance
premiums that's up from 2.25 percent one
year ago
it will likely cost these new hampshire
policyholders 7.8 million dollars this
year and you see that referenced on the
sheet i passed around
experience has shown that states
exchanges that run would get insured at
least operate at 40 50 percent less than
what the federal
exchange charges
the potential savings to new hampshire's
individual policyholders then would be
just under potentially four million
all that's well and good um the big
question is what do we do with these
savings these savings could be sent back
to those insurance premium
policyholders the individual market
holders
or they could be leveraged the federal
government for innovation grants will
match state efforts at premium reduction
uh 2-1 3-1
sometimes even higher than three to one
so if we took that four million dollars
and used it for overall premium
reductions we have the ability to with
the federal match uh have a savings of
12 million dollars
16 million dollars maybe more
that's significant because you recall
that two years ago we implemented a
reinsurance pool to reduce the premiums
in the individual market using the 1332
waiver
that helped drive down the individual
insurance rates 16 percent
but that was funded by a fourteen
million dollar assessment also known as
a tax on all health insurance policies
in the state
everybody's insurance premiums went up
especially those for small businesses if
we could use the savings from switching
to a state exchange get the federal
match use that to fund the reinsurance
program we have the ability then to
reduce eliminate that tax increase that
was passed on to small businesses and
large businesses across the state
so in conclusion both red states and
blue states want more control over their
health insurance decisions and now that
states are not required to create their
own custom state exchange from scratch
and can rely on off-the-shelf solutions
from national vendors it's time for new
hampshire to seriously consider a switch
to state exchange um i'd be happy to
answer any questions or you may want to
hear from mr sparks first that's up to
representative johnson has a question
on the as you put uh off the shelf
software what's the cost for the the
state to be enrolled in something like
that or purchase this off the shelf
software so uh probably uh mr sparks
should answer that more directly but
uh there is uh some upfront costs the
federal government will uh for a state
moving to a state exchange i believe
it's still the case uh they up to two
million dollars for that uh and then the
contracts have been structured for
states that don't want an upfront cost
any extra startup cost just rolled into
the contract and just amortized over the
period so the upfront cost can be as low
for the question inquiry
so there's a monthly fee in order to
operate this program
these programs correct there was so the
the current fee paid to healthcare.gov
it's about 2.75
uh the the off-the-shelf packages can do
it for 40 to 50 less but it's still a
well i don't know it's a monthly
assessment or a yearly but there is
something yeah either way there is
something whether it's going to the the
feds or uh staying within new hampshire
and part of it going to private
contractors
okay uh representative fargo
um thank you for that information um
i think one of the concerns that i have
and i'm questioning this is you talk
about the possibilities of being able to
help the consumer or the policyholder by
reducing premiums but there's nothing in
this bill that determines how that
savings would be used and while
it
it sounds terrific we could reduce their
premiums and things like that i don't
see anything in the bill itself that
that would guarantee that the
policyholder would benefit from this
change and we're saying that we we would
allow them to do this study make the
determination
um without the people having a voice and
that
is
is that correct
thank you for the question um it takes
about 18 months to start an exchange so
the earliest we would see this start
would be uh january of 2024 at which
point it would part of the budgetary
process of the next legislature anyways
i believe so i agree with you it doesn't
specifically say what's going to happen
with the money that's a policy decision
for the legislature at that time to
decide
thank you representative
thank you very much um i'm a little bit
confused about the status of this
exchange or enterprise is it is it a a
private enterprise is it a public
enterprise or is it sort of a
quasi-public private enterprise the
exchange itself i think mr sparks is
probably better able to answer that in
his testimony he has had experience
running various exchanges um so i'll
okay go ahead
thanks so much
thank you mr chairman members i
appreciate the opportunity to testify
today my name is jason sparks uh
representing get insured and uh i really
appreciate the fact that you're holding
this hearing today and and uh discussing
uh this bill and uh
the need for uh new hampshire to
really take the chance to
exert greater control over its
healthcare future
prior to joining just a little bit about
myself prior to joining get insured
i helped the chief information officer
role at the dc
health insurance agency
d.c health link which was the
state-based exchange for the district of
columbia
so i was in a senior policy
senior leadership position in one of the
state-based exchanges
that mr bregman spoke about
in my four years in that capacity i had
the opportunity to work on
the marketplace's successful
implementation and operations uh prior
to
my experience with dc link
i worked at enroll america which was the
national nonprofit that was focused on
education and outreach
around
health insurance
so based on those experiences my more
than 10 years in the public and private
sectors in healthcare policy i can tell
you the firsthand uh tell you firsthand
of the need uh for states to really take
control
and regulate uh and and and take charge
over their health insurance markets
um i believe that states rather than the
federal government
are in the best position to be
responsive to and to address the unique
needs that you have
in your markets
unique needs for your citizens your
communities you're at the forefront of
finding creative and innovative
approaches to address the crises that we
all know exist
in healthcare in health insurance
whether it's costs inequities
coverage
issues
and
what we've seen in my experience is that
establishing a state-based exchange can
be an important step to help new
hampshire begin to chart its own course
in health care
so
to a prior question under federal law
each state
must
have a
exchange a public health
insurance exchange
whether the federal government runs that
exchange as
it does for new hampshire on
healthcare.gov or whether the state
establishes a state-based marketplace
that operates on a
a platform that the state develops
in-house
as some states have done or whether they
each state
must have a
under federal law must have a private or
must have a a health insurance exchange
this is not optional
in 2022
over 52 000 granite staters
enrolled in health insurance through
healthcare.gov
that was a fairly significant increase
over the prior year which i believe was
about 44 000 46 000 in that range
um so this is not an insignificant
number of folks who are who are
enrolling in coverage
um
peter mentioned that the 1332 waiver is
a great example of where the state can
take you know when states take
local control and responsibility for
state health policy you can really drive
innovation mention that that that
decrease in
premiums in year one
and and um
you know that's that's
a function of that reinsurance program
uh there was a question earlier about
um
what states have been successful
in establishing
um
state-based exchanges
and uh i would point to pennsylvania as
an example so in pennsylvania in 2020
they established a state-based exchange
they happened to use our technology get
insurance platform
uh in addition to establishing a
state-based exchange they also
established a reinsurance program that
year
and this is uh and and what they were
able to do
is establish both of those programs
for
essentially the cost of one program and
they were able to save money and they
were able to drive down the cost of
premiums for
their consumers they were able to do all
of that
save money
not redirect funds to the federal
government because that
spigot got turned off they didn't have
to send those
those those federal user fees to
the federal government because they were
just using their state-based exchange
and that's an example of a successful
program and and in the most recent open
enrollment period they saw about 11
percent enrollment growth so they're
operating
a reinsurance program that's being paid
for
not by
an assessment against all on all
carriers but it's being paid for it's
being funded by
these lower reduced user fees and
they've been able to reduce
consumer premiums on the individual
marketplace so all of these programs
i'd also point to the pandemic as being
a real life example of how state-based
exchanges
are able to provide states with
flexibility policy flexibility it's one
of the key
components of state-based marketplaces
when you're on the federal marketplace
you're tied to whatever the federal
government does from a technology
standpoint they make decisions
the
36 states that use it that use
healthcare.gov
are
going that direction right you don't get
a choice
if you if you're operating on a
state-based marketplace on your own
platform you get to make your own policy
decisions we saw that
during the pandemic during covid states
running their own platforms again
whether it's a state that developed
their own technology a state that used
our you know get insured uh operated
platform or state that used another
vendor's platform uh were able they were
able to make those policies those those
local policy decisions that made sense
for their
uh community uh and for their consumers
um
an example of that is uh special
enrollment period so
uh
wanting to to ensure that consumers who
were impacted by the pandemic could come
in and enroll
uh
irrespective of the time of the year
they were able to make those system
changes and do that so
very quickly
uh i would i would just point to three
overarching reasons why
um we believe that new hampshire should
establish a state-based marketplace one
we've talked about it uh
gives you the ability to establish local
control more control over the direction
of the health insurance market
it helps you protect against restrictive
and potentially harmful
federal regulations
number two again we've spoken a bit
about this
we're now in a place where there's
better technology
and and we've been able to drive down
costs it's much easier to transition
to
a state-based marketplace than it was
four five six seven eight nine years ago
uh getting sure it is currently
uh transitioning georgia state of
georgia off of the federal marketplace
onto the get insured platform
we started that project in january of
this year
they're going to go live in on november
1st of this year
very short timeline
going to be successful
better technology lower costs
and then third as was previously
mentioned a well-designed state-based
marketplace can really serve as a
foundation for future
uh creative and market-based reforms so
as you're thinking about you know where
you want to go
directionally
from a regulatory standpoint from a
policy standpoint having that technology
framework in place
gives you the flexibility that you don't
have today
running on the federal platform
let me stop there and and see what
additional questions
the committee has
representative terry
thank you sir and thank you for uh
remembering my question and providing
that information that initial question
um
this sounds like a train that's moving
in just one direction
and to be more specific and to be clear
appears as though
there are increasing number of states
that are moving from the federal
model to the state based models
is in fact that the case
um
can it go the other way
the reason i asked that question is
because i i came from a state that
adopted a state-based model initially
and it had to be kind a lot of problems
and there was talk about
giving it up and going back to the
federal model
so um
so that i don't have to keep asking if i
can ask follow-up questions
um is it in fact true that there are
increasing number of states that are
moving from federal to state
have any states that you're aware of
going back
to the federal model and i guess finally
with respect to the state-based models
what was the the base
beginning in 20 what year was it 2010
when
when this went into then the law went
into effect and how many have come on
board since then
so it's really a three-part question and
i
did that so that i didn't have to keep
asking if i could ask follow-up
questions so thank you for making a note
of that i'd appreciate it absolutely
there so
they're great questions um if i could
take them a little bit out of order
um
so
in 2019
one state transitioned from
the federal platform to
a state-based exchange
in 2022 states did in 2021 three states
did
and in 2022 one state is
um
so
it's
it's a trend
um
but
uh it it it's certainly a trend and and
do some quick math here um
about 40 to 45
increase
from the baseline uh
from between 2018 and 2022.
um in terms of how many states
there were
initially in 2020 or in 2010 i should
say
um that we'd have to i think come back
to you on
uh unless you want to unless you want me
to sit here and try to think through
real quickly which i don't think you
want me to do um i'd rather not guess at
it and and would rather get back to you
on that and how he gave up and how many
gave up um
so a couple did a couple transitioned
off um
uh
nevada transitioned
back to
nevada became a
state-based marketplace
i believe in 2010
in early days
had an unsuccessful
launch as a state-based marketplace went
back to the federal marketplace
transitioned
back to a state-based exchange on our
platform on the get insured platform
in 2019
kentucky
transition kentucky was a successful
launch in 2010.
they moved off of they moved from the
state-based exchange back to the federal
platform
in the mid-2010s
and in 2021 went back to being a
state-based exchange
um so there's been a couple of those
that have gone back and forth
um
i'd have to think real hard and again
probably do research and and and get you
follow-up information on any that have
that were state-based exchanges and are
still operating on the federal
marketplace
mr trump one quick follow then
thank you for the question thank you
it seems as though
the passage of time
and the continuing work in developing
refining
state-based exchanges
that the trend is
towards states looking more favorably on
adopting their own models perhaps for
some of the reasons that have already
been cited in the initial testimony
would that be
generally
true it was a statement it would okay
thank you
thank you and if i could jump in
ribs and fargo
yes thank you um again i have two
questions
would you say that the growth in this
industry has been a byproduct in the
last couple years of the
great resignation and the covet issues
because people have become unemployed
and have had to search out
insurance solutions because they aren't
being provided by an employer
it's an interesting question i i
so given the
um
the law the relatively long
runway that was earlier alluded to
that we typically see so
generally
it takes
a fairly
long time
from
the time that a state makes a decision
that it wants to establish a state-based
marketplace
from that point to the time they issue
an rfp
to the time that a contract's awarded to
the time that it actually goes live
that's typically
two to two and a half to three years
um virginia is an example here
virginia passed legislation in
2019 2020
to become a state-based exchange
they just last friday
issued a request for proposal
first of april um so that's a you know
like a
two and a half year
period
to get an rfp out on the request for a
proposal
out on the street
um for a
exchange that will go live on november
so
it it it may be
that
that that there's some of that at play
representative but i think it's more a
function of
states
seeing the benefit and and talking to
one another
about
uh
the fact that these products are now
not costing in the early days
representative
to build a
from scratch because these products were
not available
off the shelf
these products
these products cost 100 120 150 million
dollars to build that wasn't even
talking about maintenance costs
and and the cost
to to to
implement these now is is a small
fraction of that
and so i think it's more about
these just being much
easier to implement and the benefits to
state being much more to states being
much more
straightforward
when looking at
when you
establish a state-based exchange
you get the benefits of
things like better integration with your
state medicaid agency
so
um
right now when
you're operating on
healthcare.gov
um
if your state medicaid agency
needs to make a change a tech you know
technical change they've got to reach
out to somebody in baltimore and maybe
they'll get a call back maybe they won't
just that that
that that communication it's not like
going down the hall or going across the
street and having a conversation
um or having a vendor who's on the hook
contractually
so so being able to establish that kind
of
you know much closer integration between
agencies
internally is one example being able to
have control over that data
again rather than the data living in
baltimore not being accessible to the
states
having it be
accessible you know at a moment's notice
i think it's more about that
representative than about
uh the impacts of the pandemic and and
covet
my second question
you talk a lot about the disadvantages
of the federal program but i think one
of the things that i see is the benefit
of
the federal program provides protections
that the state
could take away from the consumer by
not adhering to the
conditions of the for instance the
affordable care act and the state
when they're in control does not have to
provide the same benefits
they can change the benefit packages at
will once the control is in the state
and i don't necessarily
i don't know if that's an advantage and
i'm thinking of a consumer protection
perspective and then federal regulations
look down on but i i think that they
provide a safety net for people to make
sure that they have good coverage and
that they have the benefits the
maternity benefits the pre-existing
conditions and all those things that we
value here so
um
how do you address that i mean once the
we give up that control and it it gets
to a state level is there
are there any guard rails protecting
the consumers in the state at that point
so so establishing a state-based uh
exchange when you establish a
state-based exchange
part of the process that the state goes
through
is a comprehensive
uh engagement and review
with cms
and its sub units uh like cisco uh i'm
sorry the the center for uh medicaid
uh and medicare services uh which is a
subunit of uh
the federal department of health and
human services
so
uh
cms are the
are the unit inside of
health and human services
that oversee the affordable care act
and
there are
there is significantly there are
significant regulatory
oversight
in the establishment of the state-based
exchange in terms of
security oversight establishing the
connection between the state-based
exchange
and
the
data services to which the state to
which uh the states exchange the state
exchange
connects in order to transact data
because we still need to verify
you know data you know information with
federal data sources for example um
and there are there are other
um
there are other validations and and
other uh
uh
pr you know uh
guardrails that are in place uh to
validate
that things like
uh you know essential health benefits
are
uh
being offered
you know absent the state
um
seeking a waiver from
the
provision of essential health benefits
um the state would
you know still
through the department of insurance
um
the carriers would still
need to be providing all of the
essential health benefits
that are detailed in the affordable care
act
okay
representative
thank you for your testimony today uh
you are an employee of get insured is
that correct i am
um could you describe your competition
and how they compare to your services
and
you know their strengths and weaknesses
maybe thank you
sure sure so um it's a relatively
uh small
they're a relatively small number of
suppliers that operate in the health
insurance marketplace
space
probably three or four
key suppliers
that offer health insurance
exchange technology solutions
and
get insured
currently operates the technology in
eight now with georgia
of the i believe it's 18
states that are operating state-based
exchanges
uh and the other
states are
scattered across they're a mix
some states as i mentioned
have decided to in-source where they've
got you know state staff
maryland's an example of that
um
colorado i believe is another example of
that
and then there are other states that
have
uh larger technology vendors that are uh
supporting their
their services
further question
thank you uh what are the names of the
companies that are in the same space as
you are and uh second half of the
question does the bill allow for a
homegrown
exchange if the insurance department so
desires
uh so those two questions names of
competition and
homegrown possibility
sure
so
i can speak to the former
so the names of the competition
would be
deloitte
idea crew
and
optum
would be the three that are
currently operating
uh
or supporting
health insurance exchanges along with us
not along with us but in the same space
with us
uh and then with respect to homegrown so
this would require basically a
procurement process should the
department decide to proceed with it uh
and so any company would be able to bid
on that and that obviously requirements
to be met in terms of the documents but
yeah it would be an open uh competitive
bid uh for something to present to the
executive council
uh if i can follow up on one of the
things too was asked about states that
have switched from a state-based plan
back to the national plan the federal
plan the ones i'm aware of um the three
that i'm aware of uh two were mentioned
nevada and kentucky and i think the
third was oregon
the three of them all if my recollection
is correct all built their own custom
programs in-house uh and two of them
struggled very early on i'm not even
sure if ever got off the ground um and
then one did but they are in such
trouble they moved to the state exchange
i think two of the three are in the
procurement process to move back to a
state exchange and the third i think is
about to start the procurement process
so the three that have gone from state
to federal uh are now planning to go
back to state uh state yeah
okay next is mclear
herbert and then
um thank you very much i i i think you
sort of talked around it but i really
like a direct answer as to how this
enterprise is set up is it a private
for-profit enterprise is it a public or
is it a
quasi-public-private enterprise i i
nobody answered that directly to my
knowledge
yes sir thanks for the question so it is
a
uh
generally it's either established as a
the health insurance exchange is
generally established either as a
quasi-independent government agency uh
or a division within
a department of insurance
that's how we typically see it but it's
a government
run
uh entity that then contracts with
a
private vendor
but it's just that's just a contractual
relationship and so
you know where we operate
we have a strict you know we have a
contract
to provide
implementation services and then
maintenance and operation services there
was a question earlier about sort of
what that looks like from a from a
fee standpoint
and it's essentially a licensing fee
is what the structure is
and um
that operates on a we
on the implementation side we
uh
factor in uh
kind of amortize the implementation cost
and then on the maintenance side on an
ongoing basis
that's just paid on a monthly basis
but the the entity the exchange itself
is is a
government entity
um
for my reading not not just in in this
particular area but uh
what i'm listening to is the
financialization of what used to be a
public enterprise
so in other words where uh
a public-private partnership or a
non-profit
uh
you know convinces a state to
allow them to run a program that was
otherwise a public enterprise
so that's that's called the
financialization now i've read a lot
about
the history
plus or minus
on the financialization of public
enterprises
the record is not all that stellar
my question is
one
what happens if if the federal
government allows medicare to
negotiate pricing
does it does that benefit trickle down
somehow
to to a state-run uh
platform
i mean how how would that work because
at some point
we have a very expensive national
program
because there is any there isn't any
competition
uh in certain areas partic particularly
prescription drugs so
i'm a little skeptical that a smaller
organization will be able to negotiate
higher better pricing
than would a federal negotiator
and the federal negotiator hasn't even
been called in to sit at the table yet
so i'm trying to figure out what the
relationship would you still be
competitive would you be able to benefit
from that negotiation if it did happen
in the future
if we had an exchange
and it was your your business to uh
uh run it
uh as efficiently as you can and then uh
the federal you know medicare becomes
universal health care or at least they
get to negotiate pricing is that pricing
going to get trickled down to
the state exchanges so representative
herbert if i could
sort of back up half a step on the
question
what we do fundamentally is
we replace the technology
that the federal
government currently provides
we're not involved you know we're not
involved in
the operation of the health insurance
plans we're not involved in the
collecting of the premiums
we're not involved in the negotiating of
the prices
we are
replacing the
the guts of the technology
um
and the
the
the foundation of the technology and the
plumbing of the technology that the
federal government
that that the the people of ma of of new
hampshire
are paying 2.75 percent
right now
to use
um
we're replacing that with with our
technology solution
and and and that that's that's that's
our that's our business model and so
um
we don't receive any
financial benefit at all
from
you know anything that happens
with respect to
uh
you know if the
what happens over with the department of
insurance
uh if they negotiate
you know if they change the plan design
or benefit design or prescription
benefit design or
formularies or any of that
we are
an agnostic
uh
system provider technology provider
that's making the technology available
of the of the program and so
there's no financial benefit that would
accrue to us of any of any change
let's make this easy
okay this is just the front end this is
just you signing up
remember when obamacare first went in
and the federal government software
crashed on the first day
that's what we're trying to avoid that's
why we made the decision not to at that
time we were afraid
but in the end of the day we did do the
federal
all this is talking about is the person
signing up this is not about
reimbursement rates or whatever to the
providers this is simply the collecting
the money
so think about it how much does it cost
to have you go online to amazon and
that's all they care about these guys
are just taking the order and they
hopefully they get you a card in your
hand and then you can take that to a
provider and at that point they've
earned their
2.75
that's all the federal government is
okay um i have one further further uh oh
and it's a policy question and that is
uh that even though the uh uh the
business uh this man represents is a a
technical
technocratic pitch
in terms of software company software
company in terms of
i'm still concerned about
there is nobody there
to uh worry about policy
and and the fact of the matter is
some of the policies i'm seeing in this
state right now i'm very very concerned
about so it's they're just going to do
what they're told to do their their
answer is going to be very simple their
job is to make sure we don't have any
problems that nobody no constituent
complains that they had a problem
getting signed up
that's their mission
simple as that
and mr chairman if i could add
um we actually do have um a a policy
team
in-house
um
through our our years of experience
establishing exchanges
and helping states to to stand up
state-based exchanges we've learned a
lot um we've learned a lot that that
works we've learned a lot that doesn't
work frankly um and we've
been able to
we've learned that we've been able to
offer
advice um and and be consultative
during the
um
implementation process
and so we have
uh we have we have some policy folks on
staff that are able to assist in that
process um we naturally defer to
you know the state's policy
uh experts
but we're able to
thanks
thank you
okay well said thank you very much
uh tyler brennan from the insurance
department that uh is neutral on this
bill
thank you tyler brandon life and health
director with the new hampshire
insurance department and yes we don't
have a position on the bill we do have
a couple of concerns but um
just to give you a little bit of
background new hampshire is considered a
partnership state so we work with the
federal government the exchange
mechanism through healthcare.gov
and what we do is we get the products
sent to us by the insurance carriers we
make sure they comply with with state
and in turn federal laws and then we
recommend those products for approval
by the federal government and to be
included on that that federal exchange
where people can buy it
i you know listening to some of the
questions i think it's appropriate that
there is a level of confusion about what
we're talking about that's sort of the
technical interface what's the policy
decision what's the insurance regulation
um
it's a little both or potentially could
be and uh and i think that there were a
number of
quotes out there about the costs and the
potential savings and i think we agree
with all of them there's we're spending
close to eight million now
um potentially you could save some money
if you went with a kind of a state-based
system
we actually got a request from senator
bradley last year to to look into this
and do some research about sort of the
opportunities and the risks associated
with the state-based exchange in new
hampshire
nothing like a robust in-depth analysis
of whether or not new hampshire should
do a should do in a state-based exchange
but really one that just tees up the
issues does some research about
different states that's what's actually
what i'm handing around there's a letter
from the commissioner and there's the
front page and the executive summary
from the report this morning i emailed
you a link to the full report that's on
there
but the actual estimate provided by our
contractor suggested that the cost to
the state would be between four and a
half and 8.9 million and part of that is
what kind of decisions you have at the
state level
there are obviously a number of
advantages when you've got state
flexibility the elephant in the room is
geez we really hope this works um it's
not only tied to commercial carriers
this uh the link to medicaid and dhhs is
a big part of the process
so they're a huge stakeholder in all
this obviously sort of the in order to
get the premium subsidies that most
people do when they go through the
exchange even in a wealthier state like
new hampshire you have to buy the
products from the exchange you can't get
the subsidies if you buy the product
separately off the exchange so that's
kind of a big thing it's a really
important role and indeed there were a
lot of technical challenges initially
with the pedal exchange some many of
them very public most the systems today
do work pretty well um looking back on
the fees associated they've mostly gone
down uh they were three and a half
percent as recently as 2019
they are 2.75 now there was the
reference to 27.75 being higher the
initial proposal last year did suggest
it was going to be lower and then they
that analysis i think that you could
take a look at does tee up some
questions that are big policy decisions
and that brings me really to kind of the
insurance department's main concern with
the bill is that you're asking the
insurance department to really play a
much more significant role in a policy
decision than we normally would um even
the sort of that the investment in
something like a state-based exchange on
the low end of the scale would increase
our budget probably by 50 percent
senator ray white who really championed
the effort in new hampshire when it was
initially being debated i had four-hour
meetings of hearing from different
stakeholders about what the state-based
exchange would be what it would look
like and um and really what kind of
investment we'd have at a local level
they're uh one of the the pieces of
information that didn't wasn't mentioned
i think is an advantage when you do a
state flexibility
um during the years i think 2016 to 2018
the federal government actually scaled
back so the investment in
navigators and outreach to people get
people on the on the exchanges
the state-based exchanges didn't see a
drop in enrollment because they were
doing that themselves but at the federal
level we did see a bit of a drop so that
might be kind of another consideration
between state and federal um but some of
the questions that did relate to kind of
policy design insurance benefit designs
those are our things that we would
maintain at the state level the
insurance department would let's
presumably continue to play a very key
role in that
coordinating with the new sort of
state-based exchange entity and indeed
in some states they're quite large
business enterprises um they do a lot of
different work they've got a lot of
different staff not only technical
pieces but um but a lot of policy work
so it's um you know i think that the
door is fairly open on this in terms of
what the state wants to do and we're
happy to support that process but we
prefer not to certainly not to be the
decision maker about whether or not it's
a good idea for new hampshire
great thank you tyler that was perfect
thank you i have one card left uh
russian chester who's opposed to the
bill
thank you committee chair thank you
committee members for the record my name
is russian chester i am a
resident of bedford new hampshire
i am opposed to this bill
we here in new hampshire are very
fortunate to have the kind of
government that allows us to be a lot
more involved with through our
representative process in making
decisions
this kind of bill takes that away from
us and i am extremely concerned about
that this is something that was done
back in the early uh
or mid
80s or 90s with our um dhhs child
protective system we brought a bridges
system a state system um and we've had
problems with it since
it saved us money but the money that we
have spent in violations and fines and
lawsuits and the people and the staff to
maintain and change it to meet the
ever-changing needs of policy because
unfortunately we are still collecting
money
we are getting our tax money back from
the federal government so bottom line is
we are beholden
um i want to talk a little bit about
trust
uh
i trust you guys i know you guys i voted
for you guys
i don't know anything about the
insurance guys that are going to be
making the decisions about my health
care
or about whether or not i can get on a
system or about whether or not i am
being protected from
maybe a nefarious sort that's wanting to
line their pocket
i want to talk a little bit about lead
time we're talking um pence
is it virginia it's going to take four
years
how much happens in four years of
government we don't have time for four
years and then by the time that we
decide we're going to do the state thing
it's completely obsolete and the
insurance guys and our representatives
whoever's in power at that time has to
start over
let's talk about
the company that that spoke
they have been
from what i understand they've been in
business since 2010
they currently according to their
website have seven states
enrolled
that's not great
i don't know it doesn't sound great to
me
um
if we go with something like this then
we have no alternative but to approve
the membership option that is also
before our legislative body here today
or not today but in this session
um
the other the last piece i want to talk
about is uh i used to work for a private
non-profit in uh insurance company in
massachusetts prior to the aca
i will tell you that
cms
is a broken system
everybody knows it
so the fact that we're just going to add
another layer concerns me tremendously
additionally i
brought forward some significant
concerns i i was receiving gift cards i
worked within the psychiatric units
i was receiving gift cards if i could
get my patients on more meds because
more meds meant more money for my
private nonprofit agency
i walked away because of that
unfortunately that's not the reality for
a lot of people today good people don't
stay in these kind of jobs anymore
because it's not worth it
it's it's not worth selling your soul
and
unfortunately this
i don't love the federal government
option but the state option i think
we're going from the fire to the fryer
and i will we i'm more than willing to
take any questions that you have regards
representative burroughs yeah just a
quick question i'm trying to understand
um you we're talking of this system
we're talking about a technology
framework so i'm not really clear how
that takes away
control from the citizens it's not a
policy
it's not a new policy it's a technical
software implementation so that's what
bridges was
um it was a technology program that we
put in place so we had a we had an
antiquated system for
taking care of our child protection
units
so we brought the bridges system it was
it was a state system we bought it
instead of um
instead of leasing it or working with
them so we bought it and we said we were
going to use are our folks to do it
it costs the state of new hampshire on
average six million dollars more a year
than if we had built it from ourselves
from the ground up and if we had
maintained it i was just in another
committee
before this
and we
just bought a system less than a year
ago it is just starting to get up and
running now they're saying well if you
want to change the policy it'll be 45
million because we can't use that one
that's one is obsolete now so the bottom
line is we're saving four million
dollars a year to potentially pay 45
million next year because now the
technology that we bought in 2022 is no
longer
capable of being used and that's what
happened during the bridges system and
that's actually what happens with all
the different technology systems that
try to interface with cms
every single year we have a huge problem
when our our systems whether it be
federal or state on the billing side of
things um try to interface with cms
thank you
so let's let's just agree that the state
of new hampshire does not have the best
of luck when it
buys a new software program for any of
its departments would you believe i
agree with you 100 percent
okay uh with that uh i've got
no more cards left
um from
the
oh
remember
i'm sorry i didn't see your hand
thank you
um i'm sorry no problem
would you
would you say or would you agree that it
isn't it isn't just a software and we
spent my career in software development
and implementation it's not
is it true that it's not just about the
technical parts of the software and how
it gets installed but it's the policies
behind that
that drives some of the
problems
i would agree that it's it's it's it's
multiple layers it's policy it's it's
people so so
we are putting our we are choosing if we
were to do something like this
the state of new hampshire is putting
our trust in a third party techno
technological type of thing similar to
what we do with our election process and
there are there are not necessarily
checks and balances um because you heard
the insurance department say we're
looking at a 50
increase in budget and something like
that and the reality is is we can't get
people to fill our our state positions
now
thank you
great thank you
okay so uh online overnight we had 20
people in support and one opposed
and i would say i look through the list
and there are four people from rindge my
constituency
and which i do know all of them
and
but then on uh signing in was joan
pangino still here
and this time she is opposed to the
legislation she represents the new
hampshire association of insurance
agents who knows what it's like to have
unhappy customers
okay with that we will close the public
hearing
say we're running behind here
i've already canceled my three o'clock
meeting oh god
so sorry about that that's right
we just got a little pause here for our
clerk to get
reloaded
okay
all right we'll open up the public
hearing on senate bill 319 and welcome
again
roswell
thank you mr chairman
for the record cindy rosenwald from
senate district 13
and that is nashua
and i am pleased to
introduce
senate bill 319 this is also enabling
legislation
that would allow health insurance to
voluntarily
offer a wellness incentive to people who
choose
to supply documentation they are fully
vaccinated against covet 19 at the time
they are enrolling
for that plan
this
bill applies to the state regulated full
risk insurance market
and
it is designed to sunset at the end of
next year
when we hope it will no longer
be necessary
as
required by federal law an insurer
choosing to offer this benefit would
also have to make it available to anyone
who's not medically able
to receive the covid vaccination
and
i'm sure just for context you're all
aware there are a number of health plans
that offer a similar kind of incentive
for people to get their annual flu shots
the reason for this bill is to reduce
cost in the health care system
which
that higher cost will inevitably lead to
higher health insurance premiums
earlier this year
kaiser health foundation reported that
the per capita health cost
of people who were not vaccinated
against kovid west twenty thousand
dollars whether they got sick or not
this is driven by the high expense of
covid
related hospitalizations for people who
did get it which
as reported
by the new york times averages at least
fifty thousand dollars per
hospitalization
and the cost of
covered hospitalizations
in new hampshire
has also been very high
at dartmouth-hitchcock for example
the cost for
a covid related
intensive care unit stay
on a ventilator for at least four days
is almost a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars and about three quarters
of their
icu ventilator stays are at least four
days long so we're talking about a
significant cost
um
that is going to be recouped through
private health insurance so
recently
the there were reports that full
vaccination with booster shots were 90
percent effective
at reducing hospitalizations
so the fewer hospitalizations the less
expense we will incur
and therefore reduce pressure on
premiums
i think this bill will enable insurers
and individuals to make informed choices
that could save us all money on our
health insurance premiums i deliver it
to the commerce committee and hope you
will agree with me
thank you okay
so but my first question was is there
anything barring an insurance company to
do it now
why do we need this legislation great
question the insurance department
believes that the federal guidance is
unclear
as to whether or not insurers
could do it now so
therefore
we would need this enabling
statute to allow any to do it if they
thought that it was going to be a good
market solution but then and then that
and so your statement when you first
started out saying was however if
somebody is medically
inappropriate to get a vaccine they can
still get a check they would have to if
the carrier offered this
incentive right they would have to also
offer it to
anyone who is medically
unable
that's a little awkward
okay so my other question is is there
anything stopping a uh since this is
only affecting small
employer health insurance is there
anything that's stopping small employers
now to give an incentive to their
employee
to get vaccinated
rather rather than having to go through
insurance can any employer say to other
employees you know
i'll give everybody a
well i don't know
only small employers it's the full risk
market so that's the school small group
market small group market and i think
also the large group market large group
well let's say anybody's not erisa
pardon right anyone is not in risa and
it's not
to help benefit exchange right and
not medicaid or medicare or
so it's it is a
limited
part of the insurance market okay and so
my last question is since um 70 of us
are already vaccinated isn't this kind
of johnny too late
we don't really have good information on
what our vaccination rates are
because
um
since the pharmacies
opened up
they're reporting
federally but we don't really have a
good sense of who's had one shot or two
shots
or three or now
some people might have had
already a fourth
we don't have really accurate
information but it is a time limited
right and if you're on medicare you
can't do it or medicaid you can't do it
and and
and i guess and the word fully is always
kind of funny because you know how many
so
currently fully vaccinated for covet 19
at the time of enrollment his current
right now is
if you're current right now if you're
over 50 you can there's two boosters
yes you can get a fourth shot
but it's
so i i would say the implementation of
this is going to be could be very
problematic
i mean i understand where you're trying
to get from but it's going to be you
know who's foley who's not fully
uh and and and having a job and i i know
for myself when i went travel to the
caribbean and uh they they wanted the
documentation of my covet and my of my
vaccines and um
we didn't really get it with those
little cards and then how important
those little cards were and then they
were given to us and and and frankly
um i only used it for my date of my
appointment which i didn't go to because
i went to
like four or five days before it i was
able to get in before it
um so i didn't had to go into vans had
to go back to old vans and print that
out
and so and then when it came to my
booster that i now i get it about how
important those little cards are and you
know kept my card so it's awkward in
terms of documenting
that full vaccination so i'm sure that
this this is a kind of a bureaucrat
offer offer to the insurance company
that the insurance companies are going
to say
we don't really want to have to
make this decision which card is
legitimate which one it's not how do we
know your information is correct how do
you know why would an insurance company
know which how many boosters is right
for you
so i mean i think you're still
considered fully vaccinated if you've
had two
yeah
i mean two
you know a first shot and a second shot
oh you were saying the boosters are not
concerned i don't think that they are
um
required to call someone fully
vaccinated
yes i do but okay
uh thank you representative goes first
yes thank you for your testimony
is it am i correct in seeing this just
as enabling legislation so that
insurance companies can encourage people
to get a vaccine if they haven't by
offering an incentive pardon could you
say that again there was some noise
all right let me see if i can say that
the answer is yes you do i mean this is
just enabling legislation that an
insurance company can use this to
incentivize people who haven't been
vaccinated to get a vaccine
to help reduce hospital
stays that have been caused by covid
correct this is just enabling
and the insurance company to incentivize
people who haven't been vaccinated yet
that's correct and it's strictly
voluntary it's yes there's there's no
mandate here there's no
this is just
allowing them to encourage people to
reduce costs they cannot do this now
because the insurance department
believes federal guidance is unclear
okay okay thank you
unless tyler brannon has changed his
mind well i can beat him up a little
thank you thank you your testimony
question answering questions
um
so what are the uh i'm wondering what
are the range of wellness financial
incentives that you envision in this
legislation
um
that i'll start with that if i may
follow up thank you
i would imagine that any carrier would
look at
the cost
to do this and their cost for
possibly preventable hospitalizations
and
look at
um
what they thought
would be necessary there was a study
conducted i think by the university of
texas
that looked
at
this i mean they
they asked people would a
you know
fifty dollars gift card or a hundred
dollar gift card
make you more likely to get this
vaccination
and
it there was a substantial
increase
with even
that amount now for the state employees
of new hampshire which this wouldn't
affect
the state
plan
will pay state employees 200
to get an annual flu shot
so
the cost of hospitalization for this is
very high
but there's also costs and lost
productivity and
i mean so that that's the one i know of
um
further for the question may inquire
clear
so who's providing the financial
incentive the employer
or the insurance company
this legislation is about the insurance
company so the insurance company
could provide a policy
provision such that if the
employee of an insured company
was
currently fully vaccinated that he or
she might
pay less than an insurance premium might
receive a
discount of 50 on their insurance
premium or a gift card or something
they could not do it as a discount on
the premium it can only be done as a
financial incentive
so
the state of new hampshire does
an actual cash payment for people to get
flu shots it could be gift cards but it
can it cannot be a reduction
of
insurance premiums because that would so
the insurance company so the insurance
company would give
through the employer a a cash gift of
fifty dollars for getting a covered 19
vaccine might be that might be higher uh
are there any other vaccinations further
questions sorry are there any other
vaccinations or emanations of which you
are aware where there is a a model such
as this yes the flu vaccine
in in the private sector
um
that i don't know about but i'm not i
wouldn't be surprised if there were
since
there is one for
our state employees thank you for the
state employees
state employees we have per se so that
oh let's go which is an erisa plan
exempt from this so yeah so i i guess
when i saw that uh wellness financial
incentive
i was thinking that you know that
there's some if you do health clubs
there's some insurance there are some
yeah
but i have no idea what is the benefit
they give to those people today can they
reimburse them back for their health
care cost i mean has anybody ever gotten
one of those ever anybody ever filed for
one of those um
i could qualify for
partial payment of my gym membership
but as i say
federal law would prevent
the carrier from reducing premiums right
because you can't reach so they did they
pay you did you have to go pay your
uh your health at the gym
and then you submitted the bill to you
and then they sent you
a check to pay for part of it yep okay
so there is some cash there is some cash
flow there's some value in that
our current medicaid law allow managed
care companies
and again this isn't the full risk
market but it's another example
to
um
offer incentives to
the people they're covering on medicaid
thank you uh tyler brennan who's
neutral
uh so yeah tyler brandon life and health
director with the new hampshire
insurance department we don't have a
position in the bill and um i think uh
by way of background it's i think most
people realize there are certain market
rules that apply to what is the group
market fully deter group market that
we're talking about um
and this bill is appropriately
structured just to make changes for the
group market so
those market rules say you can adjust
premiums for certain reasons
the biggest thing is that the way the
premiums are structured cannot be
discriminatory wellness programs which
are
not available if you're in the
individual market
can make an adjustment or do a benefit
such as financial incentive it could be
a reward it could be a surcharge
the thing is those structure of those
wellness programs can't be
discriminatory and there are certain
rules that go along with it for a long
time we weren't sure whether or not the
federal government would say a covid
vaccine was a health factor or whether
or not it was a wellness program in
october they probably provided some some
faq some guidance that said well you
know it's a reward and it's a covered
vaccine we're okay with that there's
nothing that addresses it in state law
so to the extent that you were to pass
legislation like this it clarifies that
for all the parties that consistent with
the federal guidance there's nothing in
state law that would consider
consideration of a co-bed vaccine to be
a health factor or otherwise
discriminatory as long as it meets the
rules that are are spelled out
and those are the program must be
available to all similarly situated
individuals regardless of their health
status
individuals must must be allowed to
qualify for the award at least once a
year the reward cannot exceed 30 percent
of the total cost of the employee only
coverage
the program must be reasonably designed
to promote health or prevent disease it
must be disclosed in all plan materials
the terms of the program and the
availability of the reasonable
alternative if the individual cannot
satisfy the standard due to a medical
condition
so it is enabling in the way it says may
it clarifies that coveted vaccines are
not a health consideration of a health
factor which is a very sensitive area
and it is consistent with the federal
guidance that we have that was it took a
while for us to get anything and of
course the october guidance doesn't
cover all scenarios but it does suggest
that if it's financial incentive isn't a
reward then it's permissible
happy to take any questions okay so do
we now have under that is is it that
structure
for someone uh
to get the flu shot
so the flu shot hasn't had the same
concern that it's actually consideration
of a health factor
the cova vaccine has had some
consideration that it is more of a
health factor than it is actually a
wellness type program but the flu
vaccine hasn't been considered the same
way so that's been permissible and
that's fine so there's no problem there
but the vaccine only because the
because
the idea was that keeping you out of the
hospital keeping away off the ventilator
was the
um i think there are a range of reasons
that it's considered different um some
of them could even be considered
political
okay so at the end of the day
uh are there
any so if the flu is there any vaccines
now that
you can be given incentive for in other
words
i know that i
my shingles one shot single wasn't good
enough now i got to go back and get a
2-1
is there any incen is there any
insurance company that's offering
i'd have to go back and look um i mean
typically it's when often vaccines are
considered preventive so they don't have
cost sharing so in some ways that could
be that could be considered incentive
well isn't it the same
this is different because it's more like
the gym membership
getting you think this is more like the
gym members well that's the way it's
phrased the wellness finance way it's
phrased that way right but that's that's
the wording of the bill i'm just
it would be to be honest you know tyler
you know me a long time
legislation you know for one-time events
at sunsets
you start to wonder why you know why why
we're bothering so but if it's a if it's
an
issue that we we really want to solve
forever in other words that you know are
there situations where we think
the insurance companies should be
doing that and and that's what the
wellness financial incentive is right
that we thought that was a good idea
that insurance companies
pay people to if they go to you know to
the
to the gym yeah
well we we try to um encourage sort of
competition uh when you don't need
regulations so i think to the extent
that it's clear this is permissible
perhaps employers would drive it perhaps
insurers who think that people are going
to be less expensive if they get a
vaccine are going to drive it but
clearly there's going to be a cost to
the insurer to set up the program make
sure it complies with all requirements
and then of course they're going to be
paying this reward or potentially
collecting some sort of surcharge
associated with so there has to be sort
of the business reason to do it um even
with permissible legislation like this
the legislation doesn't say they shall
do it that might be a different
discussion well that would be dead in
the water yeah
but clearly it's a polish decision
whether or not you want to do it for a
year something longer or not at all
okay
representative patusek
thank you mr chair
thank you mr brennan for taking my
question and thank you for your
testimony
is there any in any
rules in the insurance
world that prevent
a
[Music]
health carrier from offering any of
these incentives already
if so it would be because it's
considered discriminatory because it's
consideration of a health factor
the insurance department hasn't taken
that position but somebody could argue
thank you mr chair and thank you mr
brennan i just have a quick nuts and
bolts question uh the terminology at the
time of enrollment is that the time of
enrollment and of re-enrollment or is it
just a one-shot deal when one enters a
program
um
i would interpret that to mean when your
plan year begins
okay which of course happens every year
so theoretically it could happen in 2022
and also in 2023 before sunset thank you
that's right that's not necessarily sort
of our legal analysis but that's i think
okay
uh rossanne chester
thank you committee chair thank you
committee members my name is russ anne
chester i'm a resident of bedford new
hampshire i oppose this bill
primarily because
bottom line this is a form of bribery
plain and simple um
i worked for a private nonprofit health
insurance
uh company in another state
and we received gift cards for
incentives for things like if we could
get our patients to
add additional medications to their
regime if we could get patients to take
the flu vaccine or
become
consistent with
prenatal vitamins if they happen to be
pregnant we had incentives for
everything
and
the reality is is what that did is the
people that really needed the money the
ones that the ones that we try not to
discriminate
discriminate against
were the ones that were taking that
money taking those bribes because that
meant that that was like
50 extra dollars for groceries that's
awesome i'll do it i'll do anything
it started getting really hairy when
they started giving not only our
patients but us
200 gift card incentives
for ect
now i don't know if you folks know what
ect is but that's electroshock therapy
and no one should be recommending that
kind of therapy without going through a
significant risk benefit analysis with
the patient
we were not told that we had to do that
we were an insurance company our job was
to get the most money
from the federal government without with
and spend the least on the patient
um that's the main reason why i'm
opposed to this bill
um additionally health care should
health care
really
i don't understand why healthcare ever
became such the political beast that it
did
this is my nephew matthew
after his fourth birth booster he got a
he was an emt he got a 500 bonus
in flight so that he could go visit his
mom
he died the day he arrived in florida
from the cove vaccine booster now i'm
not saying that the coveted vaccine
booster did or did not cause his death
but that com but he may not have chosen
to take that vaccine booster had he not
been given that 500 incentive plane fare
and that's why something like this can
never happen to new hampshire
representative burroughs has a question
please
thank you thank you mr chair um
do you think it might be in the public
good for um
this is a voluntary program
that
we save money on somebody if somebody
chooses to do this and we can save a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars on
somebody being in a ventilator which we
all pay for
we we would all pay for so this with
this this enabling legislation which is
not a requirement means that it would
lower insurance costs for everybody and
would also free up beds we don't know
what's going to happen in the future
with covid there were not beds available
for people who had had other things that
needed to be treated including ongoing
cancer treatments because there were no
beds available because of covet do you
think that that might be a public good
that that outweighs some of the other
concerns
i wish i could agree with you um what we
know now that we did not know then
is that had we taken a different
approach to covert 19 that a lot of the
people that went on ventilators and died
from being ventilated may not have that
may not have happened we don't know had
we done more robust preventative type of
stuff
in work on natural immunity increasing
our you know all that stuff that they
talk about now i'm not saying whether
that would have made a difference but
one of the things we know in 2022
is that this covid19 vaccine and all the
all the approaches that we have taken to
covert 19 has caused more problems than
solutions
um within the mental health
situation uh within like i said with
matthew
he wasn't ever put on a ventilator he
died his heart burst
um
so
i i can't say that it would have saved
money the last piece is is that
and let a piece of legis in my opinion a
piece of legislation like this
would open the doors for all kinds of
litigation with regards to
discrimination
coercion uh and potentially even crimes
against humanity if if it comes out
representative greeson
thank you mr chair and thank you ma'am
for coming and testifying uh
don't you think by this point everybody
who wanted a shot or a booster shot has
pretty much already done that so we
should pretty much do like elsa and let
i understand the reason i understand the
intent
um and that's
that's part of the reason why i think a
lot of this coven 19 legislation is
still coming before us similar to the
masks and the other things is we don't
know what the next variant is we don't
know what the next
thing is but what we do know is that
um
we really people that have people that
have chosen to take the vax the coven 19
vaccine have um i don't know if i told
you folks but i'm vaccine injured not
from the coven 19 vaccine um
but i've been told that i should not
take the coven 19 vaccine at this time
until it's until it's been
however i can't get a i can't get a
doctor to sign off saying i shouldn't
take the vaccine my doctor who is no
longer my doctor
made it very clear that the only way she
could give me a sign off to not take the
vaccine is if she knew beyond a shadow
of a doubt that it would kill me
um that being said that's exactly why
this kind of thing
can't go into place and we need to keep
fighting against it
thank you
represent van gaal
thank you mr chair um first of all i'm
sorry and extend my sympathies on the
loss of your nephew thank you and i
thank you for the passion and the
information that you bring to us um
unfortunately some of the circumstances
you've mentioned regarding your
employment
are aligned with unscrupulous
incentivizing this is incentivizing
about health care as opposed to
the unscrupulous nature of what you have
have seen do you not do you recognize
that some people see this as
a value to society to incentivize what
we believe to be good health bearing in
mind of course that there's so much
unknown about covet i respect that and i
respect you um do you believe that
that's a possibility i believe that the
intent is absolutely that um
um when i started working for this
private non-profit profit agency that
was their intent too this private
non-profit agency was started by a
doctor and a nurse
and then
[Music]
insurance took over or or
the humanity went out of the insurance
business and i think that that happens
too much um with regards to like uh
comparing this to a gym membership a gym
membership when you are involved
enrolled in a gym membership you're
going sometimes they'll pay for your
membership or portion of your membership
sometimes they'll reimburse you but the
other thing that you have to do is you
have to sign a contract saying you will
attend two to three times a week for six
months to be able to get any of that
benefit the problem with the covet 19
vaccine is there is no there is at this
time there is no real cost analysis
benefit to the coven 19 vaccine and or
the boosters
thank you and i from my point of view
i'd just like to briefly submit that um
saving one life is is a value and um
again i appreciate all that you've said
and i understand your point of view
thank you for being here today thank you
and i appreciate and understand your
point as well
we thank you very much for coming
all right uh before i close the public
hearing uh we did have a little activity
on this spill over overnight
we had 46 in support and 126
who are opposed to the bill
and on the
sign in today uh joan pagino uh new
hampshire insurance agents is opposed to
the bill
and receiving we just heard from russian
and then julie smith from nashua herself
is uh opposed to the bill
and with that i will close the public
hearing
and we have one more left and hopefully
um
you
cindy do you have written testimony
no
forever
no no
but he he's got this great software
program that that
records your words you know it's like
you know dragon dragon speak so it's
been great for everybody who testifies
but
i think he had to blow his nose i think
no i didn't hear you but i i could see
it hear it coming
okay
we'll open up the public hearing
on senate bill 272 establishing
committee to study the oversight and
operation of the public deposit
investment pool
you might want to start out by telling
us what that is i'm going to
thank you mr chairman um for the record
cindy rosenwald senate district 13
in nashua and
we're going to stop talking about health
care now
and we're going to talk about the public
deposit investment pool which is
affectionately known
as p-dip
it was established in 1992
in rsa 383 colon 22
its purpose is to jointly hold and
manage
the cash
from our public jurisdictions risk pools
and boards it's managed by an
independent advisor
currently a company that's located in
philadelphia
and since the its creation 30 years ago
it's really grown it's now
got assets of just under
235 million dollars
and is currently earning a rate of
return
that is two point it's point
two
eight seven five percent
so it's
under point three percent
um but while this fund has really grown
it really hasn't been looked at
since it was created 30 years ago
and we think over in the senate and my
house co-sponsors that it's worth
taking a study committee look at
oversight and regulation so for example
is the banking commissioner's regulatory
role in need of tweaks and mr hale from
the bankers association is here and he
can speak more to that are the
investments maximizing the return
along with the liquidity and safety
that i would
be considering that a friendly amendment
it seems like a very complex issue with
um
with a lot of moving parts it might take
a little bit longer to really make it
well via i mean to come up with
something i wouldn't be opposed
thank you
but i'm not leaving no i know
i know you want to stay for this
okay so uh beth
galbrinia
help byrne
i'm thinking about the new bank
commissioner when i
put your name there so
sorry
and
investment advisor for new hampshire
pdip
so are they thinking you're not doing a
good job is that why they having this
study committee
i'll i'll refrain from comment on that
one
i think we're doing a good job
good
can you hear me okay yes we can
okay
good afternoon and i'm going to follow
my script for compliance sake
my name is beth galperin i'm a candia
resident candy in new hampshire
i'm with pfm asset management and we are
the program administrator
and investment advisor for the new
hampshire public depa deposit investment
pool which i prefer to call the pool
uh rather than the pdip
um
pfm asset management is an investment
advisor registered with the securities
and exchange commission with a focus on
the public sector
we have over 40 years of experience
providing investment management services
to local government investment pools and
i'll refer to those as l g p l ips going
forward
currently we manage more than 37 billion
dollars in assets across 18 statewide
pools pool programs
lgip's are cooperative investment
products for the investment of
short-term funds they are owned by their
participants they are created by and are
governed by government rather than
corporate entities
you will find lgip's in nearly all 50
states
and generally they've been formed either
by the state itself
like in new hampshire
or by a single municipality or by a
group of municipalities and the typical
goals of an lgip's investment portfolio
again like new hampshire
are safety of principle
sufficient liquidity
and offering a competitive yield
lgip strive to be compliant with all
relevant state statutes and their own
investment policy permissions or
restrictions
they seek between risk and yield
diversification and convenience and
because of these features every investor
has access to the same market driven
rate
rather than different yields or rates
determined by an offering corporation's
measurement of acceptable profits
total relationship revenue or preference
for one local unit over another
the new hampshire pool was established
by legislation 30 years ago in 92 and
was created to provide choices to meet
the unique needs of the state and local
government units specifically the need
for prudent management of public funds
that have been entrusted to local
governments
the new hampshire pool investment types
are similar to those utilized across the
country for lgips where significant
diversification among a broad basket of
in investments is a key factor for risk
management while prudently seeking
safety of principle and again liquidity
rsa 383 colon 22-24 requires the bank
commissioner to act with the assistance
of the advisory committee
and and a qualified investment advisor
nationally managed lgip that effectively
meets the unique investment needs of the
state and local government units by
focusing again on safety liquidity
yielder rate of return and
diversification
we believe the new hampshire pool
continues to meet its statutory purpose
and the partition participation reflects
the state and local investors continued
choice in working with the new hampshire
pool
the pool is used by 504 unique new
hampshire state and local government
units investors covering towns cities
the state school districts counties
libraries trustees of trust funds
commissions utility water and fire
districts and as of march march 31st of
this year assets in the pool exceeded
237 million and the seven day or current
annualized yield was
0.2489 percent
and we are proud pfm is proud of our
work with the bank bank commissioner's
office the bank commissioner staff and
the advisory committee in providing
investment advisory and other administ
administrative services
since 2015
and as you continue your discussion of
senate bill
please know we would be happy to provide
great
uh representative greeson has a question
thank you mr chair and and uh thank you
ma'am for your testimony i guess i
actually have a little bit of a two-part
question here how much was the fund when
you took over uh administration of it in
2015 so how much growth have we
experienced since then and i reiterate
my question of do you have a fiduciary
obligation to
uh your investor uh your customer here
uh that you are obligated to maximize
the rate of return on those investments
are you under fiduciary obligation
okay
i can tell you our fiduciary obligation
is to every investor
every investor that is involved in the
pool
so that is
all of those entities that i mentioned
um
the amount at the time of the pool in
i don't know an exact number i'm happy
i wanted to say 150 million but i could
be wrong so i'd rather
representative mack later thank you um
not all this money is short-term money
is that correct um we have
short term is in there is there is no
investment longer than 360 days and we
have investments that have call features
so if we find an industry
that maybe not be doing so well we can
pull that investment but typically they
are short-term investments
well you you mentioned that you have uh
trustees of trust funds correct and uh i
i'm from jackson i'm on the trustees of
trust funds in jackson
and i think when i came there we were
invested with you folks and our rate of
return at that time was
.38 0.38
the problem with that is obviously we
have
public funds that are short-term
but we had private funds so for example
we had private funds with with durations
of uh you know they've been in a couple
30 years or so
so what we did is we took it from the
the prudent uh
uh
the prudent man rule on the private
funds to the prudent investor rule
and we went from .38
over the last five years we've made uh
nine percent compounded um it seems to
me that a lot of those funds that you
have you're
totally invested wrong if i've got a
10-year time frame and i'm investing in
a cd
that doesn't make sense
investment policy where the private
funds were approximately 65 equities and
and 35
fixed income it would seem to me that a
lot of the money that you have i don't
know how much maybe maybe 20 maybe a 30
percent
should be under the uh prudent investor
rule as opposed to the prudent man rule
anything that you know again somebody
establishes a a
a
private trust fund that the principal
can never be invaded and they put a
hundred thousand dollars in there it
doesn't make any sense at all to to
invest that in a
cd or something like that
what is your answer to that to be
perfectly honest i do not delve into the
investments i'm not on the trading desk
that's not my forte
um again happy to provide information
from our our portfolio managers
well i would definitely like to know why
that is the case that everything is
invested in
in minimal fixed income it just should
not be that way
uh she's writing a note down
it's okay okay
representative herbert and you have a
real question now right uh yeah
if i can hear you
um
i don't know if she can answer actually
but uh it sounded to me with that rate
of return you're very short-term and
you're very liquid
is there much need for liquidity in this
uh
um amount of money that's one of our
selling points actually so that you can
if you
deposited a million dollars today and
your fire truck was was wrecked tomorrow
that you have absolute liquidity to
to withdraw the funds so so it's the
risk for the question um thank you so
the risk component of risk return
is uh
probably higher than most because of the
need to be liquid
i wouldn't say that i'd say because we
are required to invest in very high
quality whether it be treasuries
agencies and commercial paper
that
that's why the risk is low is because we
are constantly monitoring that and if
again if we see an industry that looks
like it may not be going in the right
direction we pull that security and
reinvest
okay thank you
representative johnson
so the reason why you're trying to stay
so liquids as an example if you have a
local city or town
and they are in between
their big
tax revenues coming in
and that falls in that just before that
next round of payments come in they
could tap into if they had a major
project
where they needed to
tap into that
money
and then they repay it if they had to oh
then they could to pay it back
is that the reason for the liquid
it's not a loan it's it's the
municipalities money
okay and as long as it's not restricted
funds for instance like trustees of
trust funds you know the town couldn't
pull money from the trust funds and then
okay and i think somebody had mentioned
about is there a flow of money obviously
when taxes come in
or um
it's like you're when people do the tans
in and out
yeah i don't think many people do tans
anymore but certainly when tax payments
come in and you know our rate is
competitive that's when the the higher
deposits will come in right okay
representative fargo
um yes and thank you for your testimony
and
maybe i'm misinterpreting this but
i don't think this bill is a pointing
fingers kind of thing to say that you're
not
doing it properly my impression was just
there's been a tremendous amount of
growth and it's just a study committee
to look at it and determine is it in the
right place or should we be using some
of this money for something else
so um
am i mistaken i mean this is a study
committee really to answer some of the
questions we seem to be posing not to
well it seemed to me um and correct me
if i'm wrong anyone um that the first
issue on the bill was to
study to determine is the banking
department really the place that should
have the oversight and we certainly
understand the bank commissioner's
conflict yeah
so so just make sure i follow all this
now how long have you been
with us with the pool yeah since
halloween of 2017
2000 who so who had your job who was
running this program before joanne
clattskin joanne joanne had been with
the pool for many years okay okay all
right so if i
i just want to make sure i understand
all this correctly because i i see in
this letter there were some issues about
how it's being paid for this
department's being paid for you know
through the banking department um
and i assume uh the two this rate here
you're
two four eight nine that you you're
taking your fees
fees are already out of it that's the
net rate that's the net and we have
resolved the issue with who pays for the
banking department's time okay
so i think the the
the agonizing question and as i i
actually said is the treasure of the
ringed historical society and the and uh
and our library fund so that we you know
they can bypass the selectmen when
people donate money
um and that is that yes you can you can
be you know
buy cds but that if you want if you want
to be more aggressive and you want to
build the fund
you know you actually tell your investor
in my case i have a schwab for one in td
ameritrade with the other that we want
them to be more aggressive
and so obviously
at your with your lower rate we're
assuming that you're not aggressive you
are
somehow
guaranteeing that that there will not be
loss of funds well that is our first
priority but when you say our rate is
low
at this time compared to what
could have been yeah it had been right
yeah right well
last year our rates were very low we
were waiting for the feds to make their
move and it was at a point zero two and
now we're at point two nine
which is the significant increase over
the last i i actually once i realized
that this was just bonds and this is a
guaranteed fund
i was saying that 2.4 does sound
actually pretty good for a guaranteed
fund right well it's not guaranteed fun
it's not guaranteed so there is a risk
of loss there is there is but i can tell
you in the 30 years of this pool's
existence and the 40 years of pfm's
managed pools never has a penny been
lost to any municipality and that's
because of that trading desk keeping an
eyes on every investment
and following all of the right
regulations and then just to last two
more questions
excuse me i interject yes um i note that
you are a sponsor on this bill is it
appropriate for you to continue
questioning on hearings i don't know
represent representatives no idea that i
was just blonde sort of
11.
oh my god all right
i'm
it's clear that i had no idea that my
name is i don't ever remember putting my
name on this bill but okay
so i just want to make sure i understand
the so towns uh the treasure of the town
when let's say after the quarterly tax
rate or semi-annual taxes they'll have a
windfall and they're going to send this
money up to you
for a short term
yes or it could be long term
we have a number of trustees accounts
that
have been in there for many many many
years even before pfm took over so even
though this is running to the bank
department you're you're
you're um
the people are sending you the check
and you then go invest it and then they
you you will send the town the check
back so our we our let's say new
hampshire
uh private wealth banks and all our
banks that we might be good advisors and
investors actually don't get to
participate in this program at all but
that's by choice by a town making that
decision that's correct um
we
the bank the banking department is
oversight is the oversight for the pool
but it's pfm it's the investment advisor
at the time that does all of the
investing all of the administration
we meet with the banking department and
advisory committee on a quarterly basis
and just review what pfm has done and
any changes in
investments we review the investments
with them
um and typically the money goes from
[Music]
the client or the investor
through an ach an automatic clearing
house transfer
and
if they want money back we pull it back
the same way
happy to provide any information you
need
okay uh so ryan hale from new hampshire
bankers association that's in support of
this bill
and we're not saying we're opposed i i
assumed your card
good afternoon ryan good afternoon well
i believe i'm the last speaker and i
know you've been well i have one more
card after you well
i'm uh one of the few that are between
you and your cars
after a long day so i'll be brief um the
only worst place to be is between you
and lunch so that's right
anyways further um jeremy honorable
members of the house commerce committee
it's great to be in front of you again
today for the record my name is ryan
hale i'm vice president governor
relations for new hampshire bankers
represent 38 member banks
that employ roughly 6 000 employees
as the pink card says we are here in
front of you today in support of senate
bill 272 i'm establishing a study over
study committee uh to look at the
oversight and operation of the pdip or
public deposit investment pool
um this is um
this is the purpose of this is as uh
former speakers have our prior speakers
have indicated it's really to take a
look at the banking department's role
impede up as well as the impact on the
fund on new hampshire's economy and the
general performance safety and
diversification and rate return of the
pool
this pool again as prior speakers have
said was developed back in the early 90s
at that time
banks were going through a pretty rocky
part uh rocky road um
they they were this was set up
to provide an option uh for for towns
municipalities the state and others to
put their money however today banks are
additionally
the regulators have have indicated
how strong position banks are
and there is significant regulatory
oversight of banks to ensure that we do
not get back to the places we were in
back in the early 90s
one of the things i really want to point
out is over the past couple years um the
bank former banker commissioner uh jerry
little um who was in charge of
overseeing um pdip the oversight of pete
up in the advisory committee
continuously would say he feels in
conflict he feels in conflict because
his job at the time was to oversee the
safety and soundness of new hampshire's
state chartered banks
however with the oversight of this
this pool
the majority of the money or all the
money and at this time it's around 230
million dollars
is leaving the state
as the sponsor indicated
leaving the state is not in new
hampshire charter banks and is leaving
in some cases the country all together
and some of the investments
this puts and again this puts
the commissioner's
charge of overseeing safety and
soundness of state charter banks in
conflict and was always looking to find
another home for it so i think that's
really where um where a lot of this has
come from and talking with the sponsor
over the past few months
i won't get into any more details
because i know a lot of it has already
been said so i'll pause there um and see
well yeah
where would it go
what's that where would it go if it's
not the banking department well that's
part of the study no they'd touch the
legislators we don't
we would be looking to you and tell us
where it should be going well i know i
guess i'll call jerry you know get home
tonight and ask him what he was thinking
but you know it's
legislators when we do a legislative
study committee you got to give us a
little you know i think it's guidelines
go with it been had with the treasurer
um new hampshire municipal association
on whether or not they'd be interested
in taking it um over the over the years
so
those are some suggestions the treasurer
okay any other
would you own muni's in this thing i
mean there's no there isn't any tax
advantage to buying munis either for the
for this particular
fund
um i don't believe so i'm sorry i i
muni
municipal bonds your time
yeah i mean they're they're tax
advantages for an individual because you
aren't the towns don't pay taxes towns
don't pay taxes so
i don't know i just
i could see treasuries and things of
okay
i think we're all set excellent thank
honorable chair and members of the
committee my name is lauren warner i am
the deputy general counsel for the new
hampshire banking department i am here
to speak on behalf of the banking
department if you had questions
regarding the department's role in
operation of the pool um i understand
there's been
a number of testimony already provided
that's given quite
in detail information as to the pool and
we i did provide a testimony handout as
well which really describes
our um
okay well just given the late nature of
the hour i really wanted to more so be
here to
provide any answers to questions you
might have regarding the banking
department's role as i feel like that
so how many other states have one of
these things and
i do not know the number of states i can
certainly look that up for you i believe
you take these notes down how many other
states
yeah you're the only one that has what
housed within the banking department
okay that's the 64 so what what we'd
like to know is what other states are
doing and who they have for overseas
where they might be located yeah that'd
even though i'm not supposed to ask
questions
but that was a chairman type question
they couldn't get any information
i have a committee type of question am i
after mr representative uh
i'm still interested in the question i
have a question
okay but now i'm gonna represent van
halen first
because ladies first
oh okay
well you pulled that one out fast
thank you my question is is a very
simple question um would the department
have any issue in exploring
a 30-year history of something just to
see if we have it right at this point in
time which i believe is the focus of
this bill and uh so as a department
we're not taking a position on us we're
not in opposition or in support as to
looking into this we would be glad to
provide any information i do respect
now representative herbert um what i
heard i thought i heard uh was that
um there was some concern or uh interest
there was some concern that the money
was being invested elsewhere outside the
state outside the country and that
i i read into that statement that the
bank
making you know a 300 plus million
dollars in liquidity that maybe some of
that money could go out into the
communities
they they put the money into the fund to
begin with
so as um the banking department i would
have to defer that question more so to
pfm as to where the money is invested
outside of the country um
so we as a department really deal with
oversight of the pool as well along with
the advisory committee so more so
um
doing the rfp and the contracts and the
like for the management of the pool um
pfm is the entity as miss galperin is
here that does the actual investing um
so she would be able to more properly
answer your question as to
where the funds may go or to what extent
could they be reinvested in the
community
i think so i would agree that the more
money should be
this is would you believe yeah would you
believe
i think it's a good idea to have some
more of that money stay in the in new
hampshire as an event i certainly hope
okay representative mclaren oh thank you
uh real quick question if you don't know
it maybe you could find it out but what
what is the approximate annual liquidity
need from this fund in other words
uh is there a 10 15 20
how much each year is actually withdrawn
and i would um i'll have to check with
pfm but i can get you that
thank you um and to speak generally in
regards to mr hale's point regarding mr
well
former uh commissioner little um
concerns regarding
having the pool
housed within the banking department
what we did do last legislative session
and hb 610 um was to address some of
that inherent conflict where
the banking departments of the bank
commissioner as well as banking
department staff were spending time
working on the pool so the rfp the
quarterly meetings
so technically that time spent was being
subsidized by our regulated entities
because we did not have a funding
mechanism to address this concern um h.b
610 back the last legislative session
was passed which added section 5 to rsa
383 colon 22 which now allows the
commissioner as well as all banking
department staff to
track our times we use our per diem rate
calculated and build that directly to
the pool that is processed by pfm of a
way of a quarterly invoice so yeah
yeah i did see that and the other thing
that i
kind of struck by
it says the bank commissioner in an
advisory committee yes who's on the
advisory campaign so the advisory
committee um it's actually per statute
the members on it at home so we have the
treasurer um see treasure's on there
anyway yes monica pelly is on there as
well as i can
various representatives from municipal
um boards let me
pull it up sorry
i don't have it memorized at the top of
my head but um
as well as so we have a department of
revenue designee
normally as well as new hampshire
government how many name how many people
are on this advisory board there are
currently
so theoretically they're meeting on a
quarterly basis correct and i guess the
agenda item is uh uh having discussing
whether this is really should be under
the banking department or not
has never been an agenda item i assume
for the actual advisory committee there
has been discussions as mr hale had
noted um commissioner little in the past
did reach out i believe that was a
begrudging you know comment by jerry we
don't know
this actually was on the agenda of this
advisory committee yes yes so we don't
he had never had any luck finding
another home
for it so we've been able to address
some of his concerns through hb610 which
right 610 please address the the billing
issues
cool
all right
learn something new every day
okay
thank you very much and welcome thank
you
the only i got nothing on the hint
today's blue sheet
and we have uh senator cavanaugh and
senator susie
uh
and are in support and then julie smith
of nashville new hampshire
uh is opposed
nashua isn't that is that that your
district
julie said well probably a lot of julie
smith
you